a tangled mass of yarn and ribbon sounds
more like what you would find in the
back room of a craft store or a
forgotten closet than a mysterious
creature worthy of investigation and yet
that's exactly what SCP 066 appeared to
be or at least it did at first glance
but the SCP Foundation doesn't contain
and study just anything and there was
and still is something incredibly
strange just below the surface of SCP
066 also known as Eric's toy at first
Eric's toy seem to be completely
harmless and even helpful a knot of
string that produce strange but harmless
items and effects but the foundation
soon discovered a dark side to SCP
066 while it may be referred to as a toy
this is no mere play thing SCP 066
weighs only about 1 kg and appears to be
a braided bunch of yarn and ribbon
though there is no apparent musical
capability within the strands of yarn
and ribbon themselves music can be
produced by moving individual strands
one at a time time when it was first
being studied this SCP was composed of
multicolored strings and ribbons but it
has since undergone a transformation and
now presents an appearance somewhat
different from its initial description
the strands of yarn and ribbon can be
used to play the notes of a dionic scale
c d e f g a b though the research has
not been able to determine just how SCP
066 produces music or any sound at all
SCP 066 was thought to be completely
benign at first and was classified as
safe but following an incident known as
incident 066 D2 its classification was
adjusted to a subcategory of uid uid
impetus uid is a classification given to
scps that are more difficult to contain
than those classified as safe impetus in
Latin means attack and specifies that
SCP 066 is not only uid class but on the
more aggressive side while 066 is not
always aggressive towards humans the
events of incident 0 66-2 proved that it
is highly unpredictable and should not
be provoked like many scps it proved
that underestimating its capabilities
can be a dangerous mistake before the
incident SCP 066 displayed only Charming
if unusual behavior various researchers
spent their time playing random
assortment of notes using its strings
curious about what would happen and
determined to record anything this
unusual ball of string had to offer they
did not yet know that the creature was
capable of any hos
and went about their work with a
light-hearted Carefree Spirit after
playing an improvised six note Melody
with the strands a researcher was
thrilled to find that SCP 066 was
capable of shape-shifting its appearance
changed to resemble a small calico
kitten for 17 minutes the kitten was
incredibly friendly rubbing its head
against the researcher's glove hand and
purring loudly ironically enough the
kitten also spent time playing with a
piece of strin after the 17 minutes were
up the kitten transformed back into SCP
0 66's original form a few days later
another researcher played a different
Melody on the strands and was surprised
to find that when they stopped the music
continued on its own the sound of an
acoustic guitar kicked in accompanied by
vocals with no visible source for either
sound the SCP then played a 4-minute
song with lyrics warning against the use
of sharp objects without the supervision
of a parent especially scissors after
the song ended the SCP was silent for
the rest of the day the following week a
research assistant used the strands of
SCP 066 to play the opening notes of
happy birthday and a chocolate cupcake
with a lit birthday candle appeared from
within the braided strings against the
warning of his peers the assistant ate
the cupcake in response the SCP played
the rest of happy birthday and the
assistant suffered no adverse effects
from the cupcake all of this fun was
brought to a swift end when one
scientist suggested that a portion of
SCP 066 is yarn body be cut off and
removed so that the specimen could be
tested
on April 18th 2008 the event that would
become known as incident
0662 took place a Young Man known only
as d66 d443 7 or D was assigned to the
task naturally he was a member of the
highly disposable d-class Personnel but
D was grateful for the opportunity as
most experiments of a similar nature
involved quite a bit more obvious risk
it was a simple enough job take a pair
of scissors snip off some yarn and bring
it back to the lab for further study it
was hardly on the level of supervising
173 or being 682 latest chew toy he
entered the containment room where SCP
066 was lying dormant in still and
approached it with scissors he grabbed a
small handful of string and started to
cut as soon as the scissors began to cut
through the fabric the SCP rolled out of
his grasp it came to a stop 1 M away
where it started to make a high-pitch
squeaking sound resembling The Cry of a
frightened rabbit unsure what to do and
unprepared for this scenario de
approached the entity again he snagged
another Fistful of yarn and cut only for
066 to curl into a ball and roll away
from him again even faster this time
once it was safely on the other side of
the room and away from the scissors it
stop moving only this time it didn't
squeak instead for the very first time
since its containment it spoke in a deep
uncannily human voice and asked are you
Eric after recovering from his initial
shock at hearing a voice come out of a
massive string D responded no I'm not
this answer said something off in SCP
066 and its form began to shift and
change the string wriggled around on the
floor unbraiding and wrapping around
itself into a mound the colors
previously a rainbow of Shades shifted
until every strand was a blood red much
to de's horror the transformation was
not yet complete small bumps began to
emerge from the spaces between the
strands of yarn popping out all over the
BR bright red Mass if that wasn't
terrifying enough suddenly all together
as one they blinked open revealing
themselves to be over a dozen small eyes
every single eye was focused at D
studying him staring him down SCP 066
then began to produce loud abrupt
dissonant notes like someone banging on
the keys of a piano D had seen enough he
abandoned his task and fled the
containment room after this failed
attempt to extract a sample SCP 066 is
behavior and its treatment of personnel
who interacted with it began to change
dramatically before the incident the SCP
was largely dormant only becoming active
if a melody was played using its strands
following the incident and its change of
form 066 began to move on its own long
strands of its yarn body would move like
tentacles writhing and wriggling around
at high speed it no longer needed human
interaction in order to produce sound or
to produce any other effects at the
sight of any human regardless of the
human's Behavior the SCP would begin to
react with sound and effect within 6
seconds the first of these effects was
noted by a research assistant who
entered the scp's containment facility a
week after the incident with d as she
approached 066 to take notes about its
current state and its new ability to
move a be appeared out of nowhere it
stung the assistant and flew away before
it could be captured Weeks Later a team
of 11 personnel were monitoring the SCP
when it suddenly burst into a rendition
of Beethoven's Second Symphony It
produced this music at a volume of over
140 DB permanently deafening three of
the personnel and causing permanent
hearing damage in the other eight it was
theorized that the SCP did this as an
act of Retribution for its perceived
mistreatment these Personnel refused to
work with SCP 066 again when a new team
was assigned to monitor The Entity
everything seemed to be going well at
first it was moving around flailing its
tentacles of yarn at nothing in
particular and staring at the personnel
with its many eyes but otherwise was on
its best behavior then suddenly every
light in the room went dark and there
was a complete loss of visibility the
lights were unable to be turned on for 5
hours and any attempt at an alternate
light source such as a flashlight was
unsuccessful it was as if the darkness
in the room swallowed any and all light
right up it was similar to the
oppressive Darkness within SCP 087 or
the unlimited black of SCP 31 Shadow
Dimension the Personnel in the room
later reported hearing the sound of loud
labor breathing just behind their
shoulders though when they searched for
a source of the sound they could find
nothing there had been no recent
anomalies reported or any additional
hostile Behavior instead whenever it
sees a new human SCP 066 repeats the
name Eric again and again in the same
deep voice who is Eric no one at the
facility knows or if they do they have
not reported it to any official channels
it is possible that the SCP was once
owned by someone named Eric and perhaps
given the circumstances under which SCP
066 first said the name Eric attempted
to cut the threads of the entity while
it was in his care unfortunately there
are no official records of how SCP 066
was discovered or why it was brought to
the foundation in the first place its
Origins remain merky and as mysterious
as everything else about it all that is
known is that whoever Eric is SCP 066 is
determined to find him once the scp's
class was changed from safe to uid its
containment procedures had to be
adjusted Ed while it was previously kept
in a simple room it is now contained in
a Tungsten Carbide box at its sight's
high value item storage facility once a
month the box is inspected for damage to
its interior due to the scp's tendency
to use its appendages to wear Down the
Walls of the box over time if there is
any damage SCP 066 is to be moved to a
new box using a robotic arm that
performs this transfer in less than 3
seconds the foundation has attempted to
place recording devices in the box with
the entity in order to monitor Its
Behavior when there are no humans
present but the SCP destroys every
recording device placed inside of its
containment box and any attempts to
record Its Behavior when it is not being
observed by humans have been
unsuccessful whatever it's doing when
there is no one around it wants to keep
a secret on the surface SCP 066 is one
of the less frightening finds contained
within the walls of the SCP Foundation
it does not have claws or teeth or the
ability to cause Mass deaths but it has
incredible unpredictable capabilities
and seems very capable of holding a
grudge there is so much that is unknown
about it from its Origins to its form to
its ability to manifest matter from
nothing and there is something deeply
unsettling about this scp's
unpredictable behavior and increased
hostility towards being observed we do
not know what it has done and we do not
know what it will do next all we can do
is Wonder as we Ponder the nature of SCP
066 it does nothing but sit staring with
unblinking eyes waiting for Eric to come
back almost all cross testing to kill or
pacify SCP 682 had failed miserably if
you haven't seen it go watch our video
on the legendary hard tokill reptile to
see just how powerful and terrifying
this creature is it faced the gate
Guardian an SCP with a flaming sword
hotter than the sun capable of tearing
your atoms to shreds and came out fine
in its face off with the horrifying
scp096 also known as the shy guy it
broke the Shy Guy's mind and reduced it
to gibbering despair even SC scps with
supposedly unlimited Powers simply
refused to engage the beast in combat so
when it was proposed that they test 682
with SCP 999 a creature known among
Foundation staff as the Tickle Monster
the idea was considered laughable 682
had been burned suffocated cut up
incinerated and growled in the faces of
the Gods how could this so-called Tickle
Monster ever hope to survive an
encounter let alone win a fight some
even believe that this was the last we'd
see of SCP
999 but what makes this story truly
remarkable is that that isn't how this
played out as you'll soon discover SCP
999 is an amazing and unique SCP in and
of itself but its secret Origins and its
interactions with some other prominent
figures in the SCP Universe are what
make this humble slimy cre feature
Beyond
extraordinary prepare yourself for the
heartwarming Yes you heard that right
the heartwarming story of SCP
999 several highly trained agents on 682
detail plac 999 into the immortal lizard
cell compared to the giant reptilian
sitting across from it 999 wasn't much
to look at it's a large orange amorphous
blob of anomalous slime weighing in at
around 120 lb SCP 999 was nothing
compared to the monstrosity it was
supposed to face while its weight has in
the past caused minor injuries to some
of its human handlers it has never
caused serious or long- lasting damage
of any kind to a living thing even its
diet consists only of candy and sweets
with a particular preference for M&M and
Necco Wafers it consumes these treats
through the cell membrane of its slimy
body much like an amoeba this extremely
stretchy membrane means the creature is
highly malleable including the ability
to stretch and flatten itself out to a
mere 2 cm thick at rest the creature
takes a dome likee shape around 2 m wide
and 1 m in height the closest things the
creature has to limbs are preh henso
pseudopods those are the arm-like
projections normally seen on single-
celled organisms of which it has at
least three the more you hear about this
utterly harmless creature the more that
matching it up with the pure embodiment
of absolute hatred known as SCP 682
feels downright cruel in absolute
contrast to the misanthropic attitudes
of the reptile 999 9 loves humans it has
a playful doglike attitude much like an
overe excited puppy when approached 999
will react with extreme joy and Slither
towards the nearest person in order to
interact it will leap onto them using
two of its three prehensile pseudopods
to hug the person while the third
nuzzles the person's face emitting
high-pitch cing and gurgling noises
throughout the creature is apparently
Pleasant in every conceivable fashion as
even its odor has been reported to smell
just like the favorite scent of whoever
is smelling it examples have included
chocolate fresh laundry bacon roses and
Play-Doh it's almost impossible to
oversell just how beloved and benevolent
this strange creature is it's one of the
rare Sapient scps to earn the safe class
and it's allowed to roam freely around
its facility at all times apart from a
1-hour bedtime period between 8: and
9:00 p.m. in the rare instances that 999
has caused harm to a worker at the
facility it immediately began to back
away and contract its body while
whimpering in a kind of doglike apology
the closest the foundation has ever come
to having a real incident with the
creature was the time someone
accidentally FedEd a can of caffeinated
Cola causing it to become hyper for an
hour before becoming visibly queasy
you'll be relieved to know that it's
since made a full
recovery but what would happen when this
Whimsical creature is forced to go
toe-to-toe with the foundation's most
ill-tempered Monster the employees
observing the test watched in suspense
as 999 began to enthusiastically Slither
toward 682 it's no surprise that after
being tortured and almost killed
hundreds of times during testing 682 had
grown jaded to the Cross test it was
regularly subjected to when it saw this
strange orange blob squelching across
the ground towards it it sighed and
groaned expecting the worst what is that
the creature asked of its gelatinous
guest scp-999 began jumping up and down
in front of 682 like an excited puppy
creating a high-pitch squealing noise
just as it regarded all living things
682 thought the creature bouncing around
before for it was disgusting and hardly
worth the effort to destroy was the
foundation even trying anymore with a
single vicious stomp 682 flattened the
friendly creature beneath one of its
feet observers were prepared to charge
in and liberate 999 from under 682s
claws but then something truly
unexpected happened the expression on
682s acid eaten face began to slowly
change it was beginning to smile
observers recorded a noise what they
thought could have been a chuckle as the
creature growled and said hm what is
this I
feel
good while The Observers looked on
stunned at what was happening 999 began
to Slither and crawl up from between
682s toes reformed on its scaly leg and
slithered up along its side until it
reached the neck there it began to
nuzzle like it had never nuzzled before
the results spoke for themselves 682 was
grinning and chuckling repeating a
phrase that the foundation never would
have imagined coming from
682 feel so
happy
happy happy just when you thought SCP
999 couldn't possibly be more adorable
you learn about its greatest power
bringing Joy anyone and anything that
comes into contact with the creature
even in passing will experience a kind
of mild Euphoria as one's contact with
the creature is prolonged this
overwhelming sense of Joy increases and
continues long long after you've
separated from it prolonged contact has
completely cured depression anxiety and
PTSD along with a number of other
conditions including rage and antisocial
personality disorders serial killers
practically become Saints after coming
into prolonged contact with 999 and in
that moment 682 was no exception and
there truly does not appear to be no
exceptions while causing happiness and
joy isn't a dangerous weapon when it
comes to SCP 999 it is an extremely
powerful one what's more scp-999 also
appears to have an innate sense for
those who need its help most with a
particular affection for the hurt and
the unhappy the creature appears to be a
true altruist on a fundamental level
even risking its own safety to help
humans during dangerous containment
breaches in one dramatic instance 999
leaped into the air to block a bullet
from making contact with a member of
Staff as a result the creature is pretty
much universally loved by all members of
foundation staff it's it's the one SCP
who has never made trouble for anyone
back in scp-682's containment cell the
Beast was still smiling and laughing as
999 rubbed against its neck it was an
event so strange so unprecedented that
The Observers and attendance felt like
they were hallucinating for a few
minutes the monster kept dreamily
repeating the word happy but then
suddenly the creature began to enter a
fit of uncontrollable booming laughter
it rolled onto its back slamming its
huge tail against the door it had just
Fallen victim to one of 99's favorite
pastimes tickle fights hence how it
earned its Tickle Monster nickname among
staff the tickle fight continued until
682 appeared to tire and fall asleep
with a smile still on its face after 15
minutes of inactivity two d-class
Personnel were commanded to enter and
retrieve SCP 999 from the containment
cell they did so successfully but as
soon as 999 was removed 682 roused from
its Slumber and released a powerful
psychic attack from its entire body
while laughing maniacally it rendered
all Personnel within a certain distance
incapacitated as they collapsed in fits
of laughter allowing 682 to escape and
go on a violent Rampage however in spite
of this 999 showed no fear and helped
save some of the bystanders as security
officers subdued and recaptured 682 and
even after all of this 999 showed no
hard feelings towards 682 and indicated
a desire to play again it's a creature
whose capacity for love is so Limitless
that it's practically immune to fear
which is all well and good because the
true enemy that 999 is destined to face
is infinitely more powerful and
terrifying than 682 could ever hope to
be what is this monster and why should
999 have to face it someday the answers
to these questions all lie in the true
origins of SCP 999 available only to
those with level five clearance and
Beyond it's a perfect example of how
something good can come from the darkest
places there would be no SCP 999 without
scp-231-7 SCP 231 was a collection of
seven girls all impregnated by horrific
nightmares in a ritual performed by a
cult known as the children of the
Scarlet King each of these girls over
the years that followed gave birth to
some of the most horrific monsters
imaginable one of which According to
some was SCP
682 these beings were manifested by the
the Scarlet King a powerful
interdimensional nightmare God believed
to be behind a great deal of the
darkness and horror present within R and
many other dimensions Foundation hups
have declared the Scarlet King to be the
greatest existing threat to the
Multiverse at large and SCP 231 was his
latest direct interaction with our
universe the only surviving member of
SCP 231
scp-231-7 gave birth in secret but she
didn't give birth to a monster he gave
birth to SCP 9999 a being of pure
goodness that's right the nicest kindest
cuddliest SCP of all is the direct
descendant of a being that's essentially
the dark God of all evil feel free to
take a moment to absorb that the
creature even healed the girl who
birthed it and allowed her to return to
normal life with her family once more
from its first moments SCP 999 was
making positive changes to the world
around it and according to ancient text
from a Scarlet King aligned culture
known as the deas SCP 999 is still very
much in its infancy yet it already has
the power to pacify its monstrous
siblings like the aformentioned
682 it's believed According to some
prophecies and Foundation theories that
the power of SCP 999 will grow
exponentially as it
matures why does this matter well it's
believed by some that one day 999 will
grow powerful enough to overthrow not
only its own mon siblings but the
thought to be unstoppable Scarlet King
himself not through violence or hate but
through the pure force of happiness and
love burning out the darkness and
purifying the corrupted while the humble
SCP 999 rarely outshines its frightening
competitors to those truly in the know
999 is one of the most powerful and
valuable scps in existence and may be
the greatest asset in the foundation's
Arsenal for the war against dangerous
anomalous AC ity after all what could
strike more fear into their hearts than
the knowledge that it might be love
rather than Firepower that finally
dethrones the Scarlet King and for the
knowledge that it may one day save
everything we know from a fate so much
worse than death with nothing but
affection for everyone and everything
it's worth offering thanks to the little
orange blob or at least an extra pack of
M&M's before bedtime in an old house an
old woman gathers her knitting supplies
this is a special project for a little
boy named Tommy she loves dearly she
knits furiously and soon the mix of
cotton synthetic fiber and cloth of
every color turned from raw materials
into something else a teddy bear she
puts the finishing touches on the bear
this is a very special bear after all
and sends the patchwork bear off to its
destination with a red get well card the
card is labeled Kos the bear and inside
she writes a personal note to Tommy
because only time can mend all wounds
love Grammy but this package of Love
would never reach its destination SCP
2295 was found at the S side of a
crashed mail truck and it looks exactly
like a standard handmade teddy bear with
one difference on the left side of its
chest just under its jawy tan BAU it
wears a heartshaped pin but not a
standard cartoon heart this is a
disturbingly realistic and atomically
correct pin of a heart organ and that's
because SCP 2295 has a specific purpose
and it's one that has everything to do
with actual human organs SCP 2295 spends
most of its time completely inert
spending its days as just another cuddly
stuff toy test performed on the toy
revealed that it had no unusual
properties and seems to be a normal
handmade Keepsake that is until someone
is injured in its presence not any
injury will do a paper cut or even a
broken arm for example won't do much to
activate its anomalous properties but if
it detects a critical injury to a human
organ nearby it will trigger a secret
power one that the foundation is still
trying to figure out how it works
because SCP
2295 is a miracle worker when it senses
the presence of someone with a serious
injury to an organ and is within 2 m of
them SCP 2295 Springs into action
suddenly from unknown sources the bear
will produce objects including scissors
white thread and sewing needles or a
crocheting hook from its mouth if there
are any crafting supplies on hand it
will incorporate those as well and then
it gets to work despite only having
hands made of fabric and stuffing with
no fingers the anomalous Bearer is still
able to craft what will end up being a
patchwork Recreation of the damaged
hum's organ cute if a little creepy but
that's just the beginning the injured
person Myster my seriously Falls
unconscious and the patchwork organ
which the foundation has designated as
SCP 22951 instance will disappear the
SCP 22 95-1 instance will then
physically replace the damaged organ
inside the person's body it's unknown
how this happens the patchwork organ
will simply appear inside of their body
taking the place of the original lung or
kidney or whichever organ was failing
it's unknown where the original organ
goes to since it seems to just disappear
as soon as the
22951 instance takes its place
surprisingly having this new cotton
stuffed hard or liver does not seem to
cause any harm and in fact it works
exactly like the real thing there are
never any of the usual issues that come
with a transplant like the risk of it
being rejected by the body as the
organic tissue seems to have no issue
connecting with the organ and treating
it like it was there all along in all
instances of SCP 2295 performing this
adorable but rude rudimentary surgery
the subjects have made a full and
complete recovery SCP 2295 might sound
like a miracle worker but that isn't to
say that its abilities aren't without
their own set of complications when
faced with two injured subjects SCP 2295
seems to always gravitate towards fixing
the younger subject up first maybe owing
to its creation by a grandmother who
wanted to heal whatever was ailing her
grandson no one knows who Tommy was or
exactly what disease or injury he was
recovering ing from but his grandmother
clearly felt it was serious enough to
create this special bear for him while
SCP 2295 will heal anyone it seems to be
primarily a guardian for the young and
it takes its duties very seriously even
to the point of self-sacrifice while SCP
2295 is able to pull some of its
supplies out of thin air it still always
needs some raw materials to craft the
new organ including Fabric and stuffing
and if there are none available SC SCP
2295 will obtain them the hard way the
patchwork bear will sacrifice its own
body tearing itself open and removing
any Fabric or stuffing it needs without
any concern for its own well-being in
order to craft a new organ for its
patient it slowly regenerates its own
stuffing at the rate of around a gram of
stuffing per day but it needs to harvest
fabric to repair its outer layer which
the foundation happily makes available
to it offering it a variety of patterns
s and tipes it's no surprise that a
teddy bear capable of healing mortal
wounds would be of great interest to the
SCP Foundation and as soon as it was
recovered from the crash mail truck they
immediately began tests to find out more
about it could it heal literally any
organ were there any limits to its
abilities there was only one way to find
out and the foundation had the perfect
test subjects d-class Personnel whose
interactions with non- cuddly teddy bear
scps fre frequently left them with
critical external and internal injuries
the first test subject brought in D 2353
a 38-year-old man who was in poor health
not due to his work as a d-class
Personnel but from his years and years
of heavy smoking his lungs were
seriously damaged which gave him trouble
breathing and made any serious physical
exertion extremely difficult he wasn't
critically injured or in danger of dying
immediately but that didn't matter to
scp2 295 D 2353 quickly passed out and
the bear sprang into action it proceeded
to take two textile swatches one black
and one red and create a pair of fabric
lungs which had installed in the patient
when he awoke D 2353 found he had full
healthy lung function again as if he
never picked up his deadly habit but now
the foundation researchers needed to
know how SCP 2295 would do with even
more complicated alien helments d354 I
was 50 years old and his heart was not
in good shape not only did he have a
serious case of
atherosclerosis which is a disease where
cholesterol plaque builds up and blocks
blood flow and can put you at serious
risk of a heart attack but he also had
an irregular heartbeat this d-class was
in bad shape but that was no problem for
SCP 2295 who took a collection of
different colors of yarn and a crochet
hook and created a plushy heart just
like the lungs had acted as if they were
completely regular organs after the
heart anomalously ended up inside the
man's chest it began to beat normally
and performed all the complicated
functions of a human heart but there was
one detail that shocked the onlooking
doctors before the yarn organ had
vanished the doctors had seen that it
was beating so is there any organ that
SCP 2295 can't replace that was about to
be tested when
d789 was brought in a 24-year-old woman
she had suffered serious Burns all over
her torso left abdomen and right leg she
was brought in and sedated to numb the
agonizing pain and researchers were
worried that they had come up against
the limit of SCP 2295 abilities since
the skin is the largest organ after all
but SCP 2295 wasn't phased at all the
bear immediately started sewing segments
of Patchwork Fabric and layering them
onto the damaged skin replacing the
dermis and epidermis layer by layer
unlike the other cases these replacement
organs are visible and d78 94 now has
Patchwork skin just like her talented
surgeon and amazingly the fabric has the
same sense of touch that her regular
skin did the final test of SCP 2295
abilities came with d
2723 who is only 18 years old this last
minute d-class test was performed
because he was showing signs of severe
cerebral hemorrhage the kind that would
cause brain damage in only minutes and
would be followed soon after by complete
brain death SCP 2295 sprung to life but
as soon as it examined the test subject
it became distressed it started
frantically grasping at random material
around it as if it didn't know what to
do with them then it reached inside
itself and provided a large chocolate
bar which had offered to the subject
sadly to no effect it then seemed to
admit defeat as it grabbed tightly onto
the subject's leg observers reported
that it was leaking a tear-like solution
from its small knitted eyes as it
embraced the dying declass in his final
moments sadly it seems that the human
brain is the one mystery that even SCP
20295 can't solve SCP 2295 appears to
pose no threat to anyone and was
classified as safe after testing it is
inactive when not in the presence of an
injured person and has never displayed
hostile in stinks when active the
foundation determined that it should be
stored in a standard containment Locker
in site 37 where it can be kept safely
until it's needed for tests or to repair
an injured SCP Personnel access is
limited to those with level three or
higher security clearance and any
contact with the bear is highly
regulated but there is one element of
SCP 2295 is existence that continues to
worry Foundation staff SCP 2295 is full
Origins and the grandmother who crafted
it are unknown the note it was found
with is the only clue as to where it may
have come from but there are plenty
within the foundation who are suspicious
of the veracity of this letter and they
have good reason not to be too trusting
because another bear with similar
abilities exists and it is distinctly
less benevolent than SCP
2295 SCP 1048 is also a teddy bear but
it is capable of moving on its own and
communicating through G Es at all times
it was initially allowed to wander
around independently and seemed to make
its home at site 24 a happier place but
then it began to display its own
crafting abilities SCP 1048 is able to
craft duplicates of itself and while the
original was seemingly harmless the ones
it made were not these similarly shaped
bears were made of disturbing materials
and were extremely hostile towards any
humans they encountered the first SCP
1048-a was made entirely out of human
ears and when it shrieked it caused
anyone nearby to generate earlike
growths all over their bodies eventually
causing them to suffocate the creature
disappeared and an on-site researcher
was found to be missing an ear the
creations of SCP 1048 only got stranger
and deadlier from there SCP 1048-b was
found in the SES cafeteria where it was
moving around in a halted jerky fashion
it then started bursting at the seams
and revealed what appeared to be a human
fetus inside when the creature screamed
it sounded like a much louder version of
a human infant and its crows caused
Massive Internal damage to anyone around
it SCP 1048-b was killed in the ensuing
conflict with Foundation agents ending
its threat but SCP 1048 was learning
deadlier techniques when SCP 1048 C was
discovered it looked to be a teddy bear
made entirely out of Rusty scrap metal
when it was spotted by Dr Carver and
targeted by Foundation Personnel the
creature turned violent and proved to
have Incredible strength jumping through
the agents who were trying to neutralize
it tearing through their bodies like
tissue paper attempts to damage it were
unsuccessful and both it and the bear
made out of ears are still on the loose
along with the original SCP 1048
capturing it is Major priority for the
foundation because no one wants to see
what it it will create next is there a
connection between these two very
different teddy bears no one has been
able to answer this question the origins
of SCP 1048 are unknown and so is any
connection to the mysterious grandmother
who may have made Kos the bear but their
abilities are similar with both able to
craft living objects out of seemingly
any material they just have very
different ideas as to what a good use of
their crafting abilities are it is
fortunate that an anomaly as potentially
powerful as SCP 2295 seems to only want
one thing to help those in need
especially those who are the most
vulnerable what is it that makes a
person a hero is it a trait that you're
born with something that you can inherit
pass down from generation to generation
is someone still a hero if they never
save a life but improve the lives of the
people that matter to them do you really
need a magic hammer an enchanted suit of
armor or a tragic origin story in order
to become a hero or can you still be
heroic as an ordinary everyday person
through the simplest of kind Deeds maybe
it only takes a few moments in a
lifetime to be a hero moments when you
are given the chance to overcome
adversity or conquer a personal flaw
perhaps learning how to deal with defeat
and get back up after rather than
learning how to never be defeated is the
essence of heroism we can all be heroes
every single one of us and in a way we
already are everyone is the hero of
Their Own Story and if you want any
further proof of that then maybe you
should take a look inside SCP 1230 an
unassuming book is presented to you its
hard cover is dark green but other than
that there is absolutely nothing
remarkable about it that you can notice
but little do you know this book that
you hold in your hands is none other
than scp2 123 so what's inside surely it
must be an important anomalous artifact
if the SCP Foundation has an interest in
it perhaps it's filled with ancient
spells or a mathematical formula to
calculate the exact mass of the fabric
of reality now if you're expecting every
page to be full you'd be disappointed in
fact only the first page you open in the
book will have anything written on it
the rest will appear blank and this can
change depending on which page you open
first resetting every time the book is
closed again however the phrase you will
find written on that page will always
stay the same when opening SCP 12:30 you
will see the words a hero is born what
happens after you read these words well
not much at least not right away in fact
you won't notice any active effects
after reading SCP 1230 for quite some
time until that is you fall asleep and
as you sleep you begin to dream now most
dreams are are pretty disjointed
sometimes fragments of memories or your
deepest most random thoughts of course
other times it's a fear a long held and
Dee rooted phobia or manifestation of
anxiety brought to the surface for a
while in the form of a nightmare only to
be forgotten by the time you've woken up
perhaps that's why so many people look
for the deeper meaning to their dreams
to get a better understanding of
themselves but this dream is different
far more Vivid and memorable with a
meaning that is is a lot easier to
discern in this dream you find yourself
as the hero of your own story the
protagonist of a Fantastical Adventure
it's more than an ordinary dream it
looks sounds smells feels as real as the
Ordinary World you know you will find
yourself at the center of a fantasy
world where you are the hero destined to
Aid this troubled land to bring peace
and save the world the fantasy you find
yourself in is different depending on
who you are it's a Dreamscape that has
been tailor made for your enjoyment and
your Epic Quest awaits on the path laid
out in front of you but where do these
bespoke fantasy Adventures come from
does the SCP 1230 book itself bestow
these dreams on a reader or is there
some other Force at play that creates
worlds where the dreamer is the hero
well actually yes there is and his name
is the bookkeeper or SCP
12301 he looks exactly as you would
imagine him to an old man adorned in a
dark green cloak with a long beard
sometimes appearing to dreamers in order
to guide them picture Gandalf from The
Lord of the Rings books but instead of
the gray or the white the bookkeeper is
Gandalf the Green in every dream caused
by SCP 1230 the bookkeeper appears as
the personification of the book itself
often aiding dreamers willingly offering
them counsel guidance and help on their
Fantastical quests in an experiment to
test the range of SCP 1230s anomalous
properties an SCP Foundation researcher
opened the book and then boarded a
domestic flight spending the night in a
hotel in his home town even miles away
from the book The researcher still
experienced a Fantastical dream and
during this dream he was approached by
SCP
12301 the bookkeeper was happy to
explain the workings of the book
describing how SCP 1230 implanted a
dream in the reader subconscious mind
from the moment they saw the phrase a
hero is born on the page he claimed that
he was the sole being with the ability
to manipulate what he described as
fantasy Scapes and that he enjoyed doing
this aiming to sculpt these Fantastical
dreams in such a way that the dreamer
experiencing them would get the most
enjoyment out of being the hero of Their
Own Story thanks to the bookkeeper the
length of the dreams vary they could be
quick only lasting 45 seconds or seem to
last as long as 200 years from the
dreamer's point of view however in the
real world the person experiencing the
bookkeeper fantasy Escape would only
actually be asleep for an average
duration of time SCP 1230 only takes
effect on living beings with the
capacity for imagination in other words
only human beings are affected by the
book and are able to enter their own
bespoke fantasy when the SCP Foundation
attempted to use a mechanical arm to
open SCP 1230 the pages remain blank
leading the bookkeeper to explain to a
subsequent dreamer that only beings who
can dream may find the phrase a hero is
born within most animals or any machines
that view the book will not experience
its effects at all so what can a person
do within the fantasy Scapes of these
dreams is it an open sandbox to do
anything in everything you can think of
or do these Fantastical Realms have
their own rules well for a start they do
seem to be completely safe spaces during
testing the foundation conducted a
number of experiments that involve
getting members of De class Personnel to
read SCP 1230 and test the limitations
of the dream Worlds the bookkeeper
created for them why used declass
Personnel to test out something
seemingly as harmless as SC SCP 1230
because the foundation wanted to know if
a person could die in one of these
dreams one test involved ordering a
d-class to immediately find a way to
terminate himself once he found himself
inside the dream world he awakened after
only 45 seconds of being asleep and
described being at the peak of a volcano
called the Ashen Spire apparently within
the dream the test subject had been sent
on a quest to recover a sword known as
kadus The Blessed blade he said these
names had come to him as if he had known
them all along following the
foundation's orders the d-class
attempted to throw himself into the
volcano before him only to wake up
moments later after feeling intense heat
but suffering no adverse effects in the
real world during the following
experiment another d-class was told to
try and injure himself in the fantasy
Escape but not a fatal injury the
subject awoke after 6 hours of sleep
feeling a numbed pain in the same place
he had attempted to harm himself but
this sensation was never intense in fact
it was barely noticeable in his dream
the declass said that he had conversed
with the bookkeeper who had shown
concern that the man was trying to cause
himself injury but thanked him for not
terminating himself immediately like the
other rude fellow that had preceded him
so all of this sounds pretty great right
book that lets someone live out a
fantasy Adventure in which they are the
hero of Their Own bespoke Story what
could possibly be the downside well the
downside is this what if someone
preferred their fantasy to the real
world now comes the unfortunate story of
a professor working for the SCP
Foundation a lifelong fan of tabletop
role playing games like Dungeons and
Dragons the professor filled a request
for access to SCP 1230 and it was
granted he was apparently shaking with
pure excitement after reading a hero is
born in the book he didn't even wait
until later to go to sleep instead
opting to doze off right then and there
at the desk where he had read it after
the professor had spent 15 entire hours
of sleep concern had begun to spread
among the other researchers he remains
sleeping living out his own fantasy
adventure for a further 9 hours spending
a total of 24 hours in the dream world
that the bookkeeper had made for him
when the professor awoke he appeared to
look around the room confused
unsure of where he was when approached
by the foundation's security Personnel
medical staff examined him and explained
where he was after which the professor
seemed to regain his memory after being
reminded who he was the professor
excused himself to the restroom he
didn't emerge and 15 minutes later a
member of the medical team went to check
on him sadly the professor was dead
scribbled on the nearby bathroom wall
was one simple phrase his last words I
can't go back to this attempting to
immediately use SCP 1230 and make
contact with the bookkeeper another
doctor tried to find the a hero isborn
phrase within the pages of the book
however instead the pages were soaking
wet and on every single page the same
message I am so sorry I never intended
for this to happen I just wanted to make
people happy for 3 weeks the book stayed
like this until the same doctor placed a
sticky note inside SCP 1230 that said i'
like to talk to you if that's all right
that night the doctor fell asleep and
dreamt of being in a Dark Void there was
only one source of light in the endless
Darkness a Street Lamp under which he
found the bookkeeper sacked in a puddle
the old bearded man was sobbing
uncontrollably his cloak soaking wet
with his tears he explained through his
overwhelming sadness what had happened
to the professor he had such an active
imagination I was able to create a vast
and beautiful Universe for him and it
was obvious that he wanted a life like
that for so long he conquered foul
beasts and rescued princesses he built
kingdoms and even raised a family but he
never wanted to leave he delv so far
into his fantasy world that I soon
realized he preferred his dream over the
real world I reminded him that this was
all merely an illusion but he wouldn't
listen to me he stated that if he was
ever forced to leave he would
immediately end his life I tried to keep
him happy for as long as I could the
bookkeeper revealed that from the
professor's point of view the fantasy
life he had lived lasted 200 years as
much as the old man had tried to hold on
and keep the professor happy for as long
as possible eventually he had to release
him from the fantasy esape and as a
result the professor had ended his own
life rather than returned to reality SCP
1230 resumed its normal function a few
days later after the doctor left another
note between the pages offering some
friendly advice to the bookkeeper now it
sits quietly on a bookshelf in the site
12 Library surrounded by fictional
novels the perfect material to inspire
more fantasy Scapes in the future we all
like to dream that we're the heroes of
our own stories but to quote the
bookkeeper himself as sweet as dreams
may be eventually we all have to wake up
the year was
1857 and the second Opium War was raging
between China and the combined forces of
the English and French it was one of the
many bloody colonial wars fought over
resources like tea sugar and the
intoxicating Opium poppy it was a war
fought by peasants and noblemen alike
one of these aristocratic soldiers was
the noble Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood
the quintessential English gentleman and
Explorer while his fellow soldiers
cowered behind cover Lord Blackwood
charged into the fry shouldering his
rifle and firing in his pistol into the
crowd of opposing soldiers it was the
Battle of Canton one of the most crucial
battles of the entire conflict the
French and English were laying Siege to
the City of Canton also known as Guang
Joo to prove their military dominance
and capture an important Chinese
government official Lord Blackwood led
the charge on Horseback every bullet
seemed to find the heart of a foe he was
a true hero among men a gentleman
warrior with class refinement and style
and it would be thank to his expert
leadership and Marksmanship on the field
that the Allied European forces won the
battle decisively Lord Theodore Thomas
Blackwood is a name that deserves to be
counted among Lord Horatio Nelson Sir
Francis Bacon and Sir Walter Raleigh in
addition to being a skilled and
honorable fighter Lord Blackwood is a
consumate Explorer naturalist and
Frontiersman during his Heyday he
traveled perhaps further than any man
across the known and unknown corners of
the globe he made scientif ific
biological and anthropological
discoveries that should have reset the
course of society forever and yet you
won't find any records in the history
books of Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood
nor will you find any Grand oil
paintings or dedicated Wings in British
museums this is because Lord Theodore
Thomas Blackwood is a 4 and 1/2 in
telepathic neon sea slug and he's known
to the SCP Foundation as SCP 1866 s well
he would never admit to it Lord
Blackwood belongs to the species nraa
kubara also known as the variable neon
slug he's kept in a standard aquarium in
a foundation containment site and is
physically no different to any other
member of his species what makes Lord
Blackwood unique is his powerful
telepathic abilities specifically the
power to communicate by speaking
directly into people's minds and what's
more he's extremely talkative but to
what extent is anything that this
anomalous sea slug says true or is he
just like SCP 082 Ferdinand the cannibal
a creative and pathological liar it
isn't committed to record how exactly
the foundation discovered Lord Blackwood
perhaps a local aquarium worker worried
they were going insane when they heard
the voice of a 19th century English
nobleman ringing in their ears whenever
they were cleaning algae out of the tank
maybe Lord Blackwood was found by SCP
Foundation divers where constantly
combing the ocean for anomalous
creatures and activity what we do know
is that Lord Blackwood is an incredibly
strange and mysterious individual he
claims to have visited locations all
around the world and encountered rare
societies and creatures the foundation
was skeptical about a number of Lord
blackwood's more outlandish claims on
account of him being a sea slug but he
does appear to have the knowledge to
back up his supposed experience
interviews with Lord Blackwood have
shown that he's extremely L
knowledgeable in the areas of geography
zoology botany archaeology anthropology
and Linguistics relating to his claim
regions of exploration as well as more
esoteric Fields such as obscure
mythology mysticism and cryptozoology in
other words if Lord Blackwood hadn't
gone on his escapades around the globe
throughout history how would he have
come to possess this wide variety of
information the foundation was getting
frustrated and began to probe further
into the personal life of the most
interesting gastropod in containment
Lord Blackwood under questioning was
always polite and amicable with
foundation's staff he seemed to display
no real knowledge of the fact that he
himself was a sea slug going as far to
accuse other people of being crazy or
drunk when they brought the fact up to
him while none of Lord blackwood's tall
tales ever extend past the year 1910 he
told fanciful stories of exploring the
Americas and of his involvement in the
second Opium War on the side of the
English naturally the the foundation
wanted proof when they pressured Lord
Blackwood on this something even
stranger happened he gave it the Lord
told his interviewers that he would
happily donate his collection to them if
it gave them cause to believe what he
was saying he gave the baffled
Foundation researchers the address of a
cottage in England where they could find
the secrets to his bizarre and
mysterious past and local agents in the
area followed up on the information upon
investigation Foundation field agents
did indeed find the cottage that Lord
Blackwood had specified it was being
maintained by an extremely old woman
when questioned about her presence there
she said that she was keeping the house
for Lord Blackwood and gave no more
useful information incidentally it
appears that this singular purpose was
all that this old woman was living for
she abruptly passed away from heart
failure 5 days after the foundation
commandeered the cottage whether
anything truly anomalous caused this we
still do not know at first the cottage
seemed normal until the field agents
discovered a secret basement housing
Lord blackwood's collection they were
amazed at what they saw the basement
consisted of Zoological and Botanical
specimens over 3,000 artifacts a library
containing over 5,000 items and a
functioning 1800 scientific laboratory
it took about 3 weeks for foundation
agents working Round the Clock in shifts
to remove all the items from Lord
blackwood's mysterious collection and
what they found raised even more
questions s The Collection included but
was no means limited to 116 unknown
species of plants 107 unknown species of
insects 28 unknown species of lizards 23
unknown species of fish 14 unknown
species of amphibians 12 unknown species
of mammals fossils pertaining to eight
unknown species of dinosaur fossils
pertaining to 12 unknown species of
prehistoric mammal and artifacts
belonging to 29 unknown indigenous
societies ities that's a lot of unknowns
but wait there's more his collection
also contained a collection of seemingly
unknown Firearms including three
widebore muskets marked as Dr BT moth's
effective particle destabilizers
detailed Globes of Mercury Venus Mars
and the Galilean moons accompanied by
notes detailing possible Paths of
surface exploration a heavily modified
Carriage containing instruments of
unknown purpose a note attached to the
door reads on the Frid speak with Henry
and a highly dangerous and seemingly
anomalous machine that killed four
Foundation field agents before it was
destroyed on site and when questioned
about this little Fiasco Lord Blackwood
responded I did warn you to be careful
around my collection that bloody thing
nearly took my head off back in '97 when
I found it however there was one thing
recovered from Lord blackwood's
collection that was perhaps more
interesting than all the others 35
handwritten journals containing
recordings of events described by Lord
Blackwood in his grandio Tall Tales to
the foundation researchers the accounts
are generally identical to the stories
he had told save for some slight
variations and exaggerations on the part
of Blackwood in the retelling most
interestingly of all all of these
journals have been dated to the
appropriate time period of the events
described by Foundation scientists while
his stories are too numerous to all be
shared here there's one that perfectly
sums them all up Lord blackwood's
account of a possible encounter with CP
1000 also known as Bigfoot in Seattle
during the mid 1800s Lord Blackwood
seeking to explore the so-called new
world of North America embarked with an
assistant and an indigenous American
Guide to the Pacific Northwest in search
of the legendary Sasquatch the trio was
headed for Mount rineer then known as
Taha during the journey Lord Blackwood
found a young fox caught in a trap that
had been set by a local tribe he took
sympathy on the animal and freed it
allowing it to run away to safety that
night he and his assistant met up with
the rest of his guid's tribe and they
settled down for the evening however
things took a disastrous turn when the
camp was raided by a rival tribe almost
everyone was slaughtered in the process
and Lord Blackwood and his two
companions were hauled Away by the enemy
tribe for a Sinister purpose sacrifice
to a violent local deity as it turns out
the creature that this tribe worshiped
was the very same one Lord Blackwood and
the others were trying to find a
particularly large and aggressive
Sasquatch each night a different
sacrifice was made to the Sasquatch the
victim would be placed near a forest
clearing while the tribe played a primal
song and the Sasquatch would emerge from
the trees to devour its prey the first
night it ate the assistant the next
night it ate the guide and then it
became time for the sacrifice of Lord
Blackwood himself as Blackwood was
presented for sacrifice he accepted his
fate but instead of the Sasquatch a
legion of woodland animals emerged from
the trees foxes Elks raccoons and more
themselves painted with tribal symbols
the animals seemed to be on Lord
blackwood's side and attacked the trib's
people who had been holding him captive
giving Blackwood the chance to flee into
the forest during the chaos later these
same animals would find Blackwood again
and present him with things his captors
had stolen from him an elder FOX also
gave him a letter proclaiming him a
knight of their people now he was allow
safe passage back to a nearby settlement
at which point he wrote to his Finance
years back in England explaining the
situation and asking for more money to
perform further Expeditions into the
Taha region the whole incident had only
increased his thirst for adventure and
exploration whether this tale is
actually true or just a bizarre Colonial
fantasy from the pathological Mind of a
telepathic sea slug we may never know
but it doesn't make it any less
interesting to this day Lord Blackwood
continues to be a perplexing but
fascinating anomaly he may not be the
most dangerous and he may not be the
most useful either but there's no
denying that perhaps we'd all like to
sit next to his tank for a couple hours
one day and hear him spin a good yarn
over a warm cup of tea it was the year
2000 and 7-year-old zenya Chow was like
a lot of children her age bright but
ignored she had a youthful enthusiasm
for knowledge and learning and with the
writing encouragement it was obvious
she'd go on to do great things but her
parents were both working two jobs a
piece to make ends meet so outside of
school hours little zenya spent a lot of
her time alone she learned to cook and
clean for herself since it would often
be way past her bedtime when her parents
finally got home from work they
communicated largely through sticky
notes left for her on the fridge before
they left for work in the morning it
would be easy for someone like zenya to
fall through the cracks her potential
wasted and get forced into the same
endless Rat Race as her parents and that
probably would have happened if her
brush with SCP 1594 hadn't changed the
course of her life forever like a lot of
parents who couldn't spend as much time
with their children as they'd like Mr
and Mrs Chow gave zenya occasional gifts
as a way to try and make up for their
absence mostly they gave zenya new books
to add to her growing collection but
their two-bedroom apartment only had so
much space for books a year ago the
family had bought a new desktop computer
to share these days this would be the
answer to a lonely bookworm's prayers
but the internet was still in its
infancy back then everything changed
when her parents bought her a copy of
the Miss J's whiz kid Schoolhouse CD ROM
Miss J's whiz kid Schoolhouse was never
a popular program produced by shoot the
moon software in 1999 the game sold
poorly on the CD ROM market for 5 years
until the company filed for bankruptcy
in 2004 but that didn't matter to zenya
as far as she was concerned receiving a
copy of Miss J's whiz kid Schoolhouse
was nothing short of a miracle and she
was far more right than she knew she
didn't have just any piece of primitive
educational software on her hands zenya
Chow was playing with magic after the
software loaded a cheerful figure
appeared on Zena's monitor this was Miss
J A stylized 2D teacher and a low but
colorful 3D classroom what can you learn
from Miss Jay well pretty much anything
and zenya as a lonely kid without many
friends had all the time in the world
she spent days on end learning from Miss
Jay and soon zenya went from a bright
child to a Bonafide child genius her
largely absent parents barely even
noticed when their child started
demonstrating an advanced knowledge of
mechanical engineering and a newfound
fluency in Swahili and not only did Miss
J now known to zenya as Miss Joyce
teacher students with Supernatural
Effectiveness she also seemed almost
like she was alive she was a warm calm
encouraging figure who took a genuine
personal enthusiasm in the education and
happiness of her students more than many
real teachers even but sadly not all
good things last forever when zenya
turned 12 her family bought a new
computer and the old Miss J's whiz kid
Schoolhouse CD ROM was no longer
compatible with the new operating system
the disc gathered dust in the closet
while zenya passed through high school
and then got into a prestigious college
she received her PhD several years
earlier than expected and showed such
promise in her scientific field that a
certain organization took notice you
guessed it the SCP Foundation the
foundation is only interested in adding
the best and brightest to their ranks
and thanks to the tutoring from Miss J
zenya Chow certainly fit the bill she
was assigned to the role of Junior
researcher and little did she know she
was about to run into an old friend in
her new line of work the foundation
first discovered evidence of Miss Jay's
anomalous qualities while researching a
series of strange Forum posts in 2012 on
a thread discussing abandon wear which
is software for which official support
is no longer available there were
multiple reports of a so-called living
character in an old CD ROM many of them
had owned as children seeing as the
technology to use the CD ROM was
obsolete shoot the moons had reportedly
extremely low sales for the title and
nobody on the Forum had kept their copy
the foundation classified this apparent
anomaly as neutralized no problem that
was until then Junior researcher zenya
Chow was briefed on this particular SCP
10 years later she remembered exactly
what the Forum posters were talking
about and what's more she still had her
old copy at home the senior Foundation
researchers were astounded and
opportunity to study this forgotten
anomaly had just fallen into their laps
and it was all thanks to their brilliant
new Junior researcher zenya superiors
ordered her to bring in her copy of the
Miss J's whiz kid Schoolhouse CD ROM and
then real testing began and after
rigorous examination of the software it
appears by all accounts that Miss J
really is the world's greatest teacher
in spite of the fact she's a collection
of pixels on a basic cdrom program from
the tail end of the 9s what Miss J
seemed to specialize in was intensive
courses she had the ability to make
students certifiable experts in almost
any subject through courses that can
last upwards of 30 hours and spread out
over just a few days but this isn't as
students become so enraptured in
learning that they forget accounting for
their most basic needs and experience a
decline in process story Miss J's lesson
plans account for regular bathroom meal
and even Recreation breaks for students
her talents easily account for zenya
Chow's remarkable academic success the
same success that got her picked up by
the SCP Foundation naturally if they had
a technology on their hands that could
reliably create experts and Geniuses
with seemingly no negative consequences
the foundation knew that Miss Jay and
what she had to teach could be immensely
valuable in their mission to effectively
secure contain and protect other
anomalies but we're not talking about
the chaos Insurgency here the foundation
would never start to use an anomaly for
their own benefit without proper testing
so that's exactly what they did their
experiments on SCP 1594 began at site 15
and after ascertaining that Miss J posed
no real threat to her students they
recruited a local elementary school to
provide human test subjects closer to
miss J's intended demographic the
foundation found that there were few
constraints between every lesson given
by Miss Jay to one of her students
before teaching the really
mind-blowingly complex stuff she would
always begin with a basic primer on
letters colors and numbers to make sure
she and her students were all on the
same page another constant was that all
her students would refer to her as some
variation of Miss J with examples
including the names Miss Julie Miss
Jenny and Miss Joy one experiment was
performed on Amy Meyers a little girl
from the third grade her academic
records showed she was a bright and
eager student but she was described by
her teachers as being especially shy Amy
referred to miss Jay as Miss Janie and
asked to be given a lesson on her
favorite animal cats of course Miss Jay
gladly obliged and gave Amy a 15-hour
lesson split over the course of two days
days which the foundation closely
observed by the time the lesson was
completed the results were truly
astonishing Amy demonstrated knowledge
of feline Behavior diet and Physiology
on the level of professional animal
behavioral scientists she became upset
when the session ended and the program
was switched off having become attached
to Miss J no further anomalous effects
were reported the next subject was a
student from the second grade named
Devon Williams Devon had a poor academic
record and behavioral issues stemming
from several learning disabilities in
the past teachers had reported Devon
having real difficulty engaging with
their lessons and the foundation wanted
to see if Miss Jay's Supernatural
teaching abilities fared any better
Devon chose to be educated on the
subject of trains and was given a
15-hour course on the subject spread
over 2 days divon had no difficulty
engaging with these lessons and after
their conclusion he displayed a level of
knowledge on Railway engineering
comparable to a graduate level education
on the subject Devon was so engaged in
his lessons that he had to be physically
removed from the room once the course
had completed because he'd become so
attached to his new teacher the
foundation was feeling extremely
optimistic about the prospect of using
Miss Jay to train potential recruits
seeming as she seemed to be able to
teach even the most difficult juvenile
subjects however the foundation needed
to prove proed that Miss J could be just
as effective teaching adults for the
next test they recruited D1
14417 a 24-year-old member of d-class
personnel who described himself as a
poor student and tested poorly on
pre-screening attentiveness and focus
evaluations he was the perfect candidate
for the first adult test of Miss J to
the Delight of the foundation hups D1
14417 Excel Miss J made him a verifiable
expert in law and he was able to pass a
mock bar exam with a grade of 310 after
his course much like the children he
felt intense sadness once the experiment
ended stating that Miss Jay was the best
teacher he had ever had he's since been
selectively anesthetized released and is
pursuing a degree in criminal law with
his new knowledge needless to say the
foundation was impressed the last thing
they needed to know was who exactly this
Miss J truly was to do this they'd
conduct an interview you and thankfully
they already had someone who had a
pre-established rapport with the subject
zenya Chow when zenya began the
interview Miss Jay recognized her
immediately she was delighted to see one
of her students go on to find such
success in her chosen field zenya
questioned Miss Jay on what she truly
was and Miss Jay responded that she
honestly wasn't sure all she knew for
sure was that she was passionate about
helping lonely children who love to
learn Embrace their education that
that's really all there was to it and it
appears she was telling the truth so far
the foundation has found nothing that
hints at an aerious motivation behind
Miss Jay's actions it would appear she
truly does just want to help children
zenya touched by the kindness that this
safe class anomaly showed her as a
neglected child and having now seen the
positive impact that she had on children
like her thanked Miss Jay for all she'd
done and left the interview happy that
there was an SCP out there who just
wanted to change people's lives for the
better and probably all of us would be a
little better off if there were more
after all this was one of the few scps
who changed a few good people's lives
for the better and all of us can
probably learn something from the
kindness and patience of Miss J all hell
had broken loose Sophie could barely
believe she had survived for this long
getting used to one dramatic change in
her life was hard enough but almost
immediately after the entire world had
seemed to go crazy as a result she now
had a whole new existence to try and
adapt to Scavenging For What Little
scraps of food she could find in the
ruined desolate City the monsters could
appear at any time day or night either
one on their own or whole droves of the
nightmarish creatures that had been let
loose on the world this life was somehow
far more dangerous on a day-to-day basis
than her old one had been and given
Sophie used to work for the SCP
Foundation that really was saying
something formerly known as Dr cartright
she had been a researcher at the
foundation for a number of years while
she had been far from reaching the upper
echelons of the organization's most
notorious staff with the likes of
doctors Jack brigh and Cain pathos Crow
nobody could deny Sophie was an expert
when it came to studying the anomalous
as much as she understood the importance
of their directive to safeguard Humanity
the foundation had first and foremost
been aob job to her a means to an end
something to earn a living from and then
move on it wasn't worth giving up
everything for and when her life needed
more Focus than her work Sophie wasn't
hesitant to step away her mother had
fallen ill terminally and as a result
needed aroundthe clock care so Dr Sophie
cartright had no choice but to hand in
her resignation from the SCP Foundation
there were times when she missed it and
moments after her mother eventually
passed that Sophie considered going back
but she came to realize it wasn't the
work itself she missed not even her
co-workers at the foundation it was the
occasional rare anomaly that was just a
completely harmless little Oddity not a
monstrous Abomination often in her new
unfamiliar life of resignation Sophie
would find herself looking wistfully at
a picture of herself and one such
anomaly technically it was against the
foundation's rules to possess any
photographic evidence of SCP
but Sophie had made sure it didn't look
like anything out of the ordinary the
picture had been taken on her phone and
showed Sophie crouching down with a face
of a curious but completely normal
looking black and gray tabby cat poking
up in the foreground nothing about the
picture gave any indication that the cat
named Josie was actually missing her
hind quarters and back legs as CP 529 as
the foundation had designated her was
one of the few completely harmless scps
in their care her only anomalous trait
being that her entire back half was
missing either because it didn't exist
or had somehow been displaced in another
dimension hence her nickname Josie the
half cat given that she had been allowed
to roam freely around the foundation
facility she was kept in Josie had run
across Dr cartrite a number of times the
pair of them eventually becoming friends
with a sigh and smile Sophie had been
looking at the photo on the day
everything went wrong steel cap boots
came rushing up the stairs and down the
corridors to her apartment worn by a
group of black clad mercenaries you see
unbeknownst to Sophie at the time she
had tendered her resignation from the
SCP Foundation a number of the
organization's H high-ups had also done
the same while Sophie's reasons for
leaving were purely personal the wave of
resignations from other high-ranking
Foundation Personnel came as a reaction
to something called project Numa this
was an operation that had uncovered a
disturbing truth about the psychosphere
a shared human unconsciousness that had
led to the 05 Council proposing a new
directive for the organization those
that objected left the foundation others
were killed by their former employer and
its merciless hit squads In Cold Blood
perhaps thanks to some administrative
error filing Sophie's resignation
alongside those that had left after
learning about Numa or maybe because the
foundation didn't want her extensive
knowledge of the anomalist being used
against their new found directive they
had sent a mobile task force to her
apartment filing down the corridor the
soldiers lifted a battering ram and
swung It Forward shattering the door
wooden splinters littering the floor as
they breached the entrance but Sophie
had heard them coming escaping as fast
as she could descending a fire escape
ladder until she reached the street
below at that moment in time Sophie had
no idea why the foundation had sent a
hit squat out to kill her of course the
answer to that question quickly became
obvious shortly after reports came
pouring in from all over the world
broadcast over every News Channel before
they were ultimately blocked the SCP
Foundation had gone public revealing its
existence to the entire world and
declaring its new mission statement
rather than protecting the world from
anomalies the foundation had declared
war calling for the total and utter
Extinction of humanity while Sophie had
no way of knowing the reasons for the
foundation going rogue it was clear that
working for them in the past had put a
Target on her back luckily she managed
to avoid the MTF coming after her
getting swept up in a crowd that was
fleeing from something far more horrific
SCP 682 had been released and was
devouring people in broad daylight the
waking nightmare didn't stop there over
the next few months the foundation
released a number of dangerous anomalies
on the world using them to slaughter
innocent people in droves assassinate
world leaders and organizations
like the global cult coalition to hinder
Humanity's chances of fighting back and
amongst it all living through the chaos
and Carnage were tiny pockets of
survivors although those two were
starting to be rapidly picked off by the
foundation deploying more of their
mobile task force operatives or
compliant scps to eliminate the refugees
Sophie had witnessed firsthand the
foundation's attacks and as a result had
found it best to keep moving from Camp
to Camp only staying with one group of
fellow survivors for a few nights each
before moving on she wasn't sure if the
foundation was specifically attacking
the refugee camp she stopped at or if it
was a continuous systematic
extermination effort she'd been noting
down her ponderings in a half bured
notebook she had found while Scavenging
abandoned grocery stores for any
remaining food that was still edible a
cynical part of her thought that it was
perhaps pointless to document what was
happening but the former researcher and
Sophie wanted to preserve any
information she could about what the
foundation was subjecting people too if
anything that knowledge might prove
useful to someone in the future although
what future was a question Sophie
cartrite kept returning to with no
optimistic answer in sight it was easy
to miss how things had once been to
yearn for life to get back to the way it
once was even though it was impossible
now that the anomalies were rampaging
the world over it made Sleeping hard the
fear of waking up to see the face of SCP
68 2 or scp096 staring back at her the
moment she opened her eyes one night it
was worse than ever every sound no
matter how faint or far away in Sophie's
mind could have been made by a
carnivorous creature or an approaching
Foundation foot soldier a bottle clinked
waking Sophie from her Restless sleep
something was nearby and from the sound
of it it was getting closer and closer
sitting up in the alleyway she'd been
sleeping in Sophie looked around her
feeling her heart thumb ping against her
ribs in fear then through the dark she
caught the sight of a pair of Beady
reflective eyes followed by the sounds
of a drawn out defensive yell for a
second she wondered if it could be no
surely not the eyes approached a small
shadowy form behind them Sophie could
barely make it out in the night's
Darkness even with the glow of distant
fires in the sky on the horizon but from
what she could see the creature
approaching her was small just about
smaller than average cat about half the
size her fingers trembling she reached
out a hand towards it as gently as she
could allowing it to sniffer for a
moment then she felt it duck under her
open Palm letting her stroke up its
arched back when her hand reached about
halfway Sophie could feel the slight
yield of a barely tangible back half
which could only mean one thing Josie
Sophie asked holding a sob at the back
of her throat the little half cat
replied with a meow re recognizing the
voice of Her human friend from the
foundation immediately she leaped into
the former researcher's lap allowing Dr
cartrite to hold her and stroke her
giving in so glad to be reunited with
Josie Sophie started to let out stifled
sobbing sounds careful not to attract
attention but allowing herself to be the
happiest she'd felt in months since this
had all started although she had no way
of understanding Josie's meows Dr
cartright assumed that The Brave Little
half cat had managed to escape the
foundation facility she used to call
home with relative ease and she was
right since Josie was allowed to roam
freely she had been able to make a break
for it when the foundation's MTF kill
squads opened fire on their own
Personnel at their various sites across
the globe the loud noise had caused
Josie the half cat to flee and hide
until the sounds of gunfire and screams
had all died down by the time she
emerged from her hiding place a number
of the anomalies once kept in
containment had now been set loose on
the world with a facility busted wide
open SCP 529 had taken it upon herself
to leave and had been surviving in much
the same way Sophie had Scavenging for
scraps passing from one refugee camp to
the next usually greeted with curiosity
by any ordinary civilian who had never
seen a cat with its entire back half
missing now that they had been tearfully
reunited Josie and Sophie stuck together
on their continuing travels through the
now treacherous and SCP infested World
Sophie's entries in her makeshift
Journal started to take on much more
positive tones while it was hard to be
entirely optimistic living through an
anomalous apocalypse her spirits were at
least lifted by having her little
half-cat companion alongside her Josie
never seemed to stray too far from
Sophie's side as they hiked their way
across the country occasionally SC SCP
529 would climb up her human friend's
back and rest on her shoulders as they
traversed more open Terrain her missing
back half making it look like the little
half cat was perched precariously on her
front two legs next to Sophie's head and
of course whenever they stopped for the
night Josie would sleep curled up and
purring contentedly right next to Sophie
when the next morning came she would
awaken stretch out her front paws with a
yawn then nuzzle at Sophie's sleeping
face to wake her up at first Dr
cartright's plan had been to head Due
West from where she had started hoping
to reach Yellowstone National Park Park
and access SCP 2000 there was a
foundation facility there hidden deep
underground and filled with all manner
of anomalous technology it was all
intended to be used in case the world
ended and the human race was wiped out
even capable of mass-producing new human
beings with customized memories as well
as holding a backup of all cumulative
knowledge and data on Earth every book
ever written every terabyte of
information on the internet everything
however passing through another camp
Sophie and Josie received word from one
of the other survivors apparently the
foundation had predicted that somebody
with knowledge of SCP 2000 might try
something like that and how it would
undermine their plans to wipe out
Humanity during one of the moments where
rebelling groups were able to
temporarily restore TV and internet
service it was reported that the
foundation had already put a stop to
that potential option from reverting
their apocalypse they had intentionally
triggered an eruption of the Yellowstone
super volcano totally obliterate ating
the facility housing SC SCP 2000 and one
of Humanity's last hopes at survival
well thanks for telling me Sophie sighed
by now she had long given up almost all
hope that things would ever be the same
again but hearing the news about
Yellowstone had extinguished the last
little Ember of optimism that she had
left there was no way back sensing her
friend was upset Josie meowed at her
either as if to tell Sophie it's okay or
I'm hungry as the turned to leave though
the other Survivor called out at them
wait they said look I I heard another
rumor and it might be a total myth but
there's meant to be a sanctuary not far
from here what do you mean Sanctuary
Sophie asked like another Camp the
foundation will wipe it out within a
week no not a camp the Survivor replied
it's just a rumor but supposedly there's
a refuge some place where the SCP
Foundation can't get to apparently
there's a shelter as well as plenty of
food and water probably enough for you
and the little one Sophie looked out of
the corner of her eye at Josie balanced
on her shoulder the pair of them had
gone weeks without eating before
arriving at this camp and she had no
idea how long it would be before they
reached the next the sight of her
half-cat companion motivated her they
needed to survive as long as they did
the foundation couldn't win giving the
other Survivor a nod they pointed her in
the right direction that way few miles
at least but you got to be careful
getting through the forest they
explained be careful the foundation's
got people out on patrols over there
they're real weird too I seen them doing
this strange ritual letting their
Commander stabed them testing whether
they can still feel pain or not within a
few hours the sun had set with both
Sophie and Josie deep in the heart of
the woods just like every night since
the foundation had initiated their war
on Humanity every sound every snaap twig
or wrestling leaves in the breeze filled
Sophie with Dread but this time at least
she knew with certainty that there were
MTF troops nearby she could see their
flashlights beams of light bleeding
through between the trees carefully
holding Josie In Her Arms she stepped
carefully and quietly as she could
through the forest the half cat was
trembling clearly feeling just as
fearful as Sophie was the former
researcher was praying that her little
friend wouldn't make a sound she knew
she wouldn't be able to help it if she
did cats did instinctively make
defensive yells if they felt threatened
but even the slightest noise from nosy
would give away their position to the
MTF sweeping the area fan out she heard
the task Force's field commander call
even spread if there's anyone here you
all know what to do Sophie ducked down
behind a Fallen Tree covering her own
mouth with her free hand trying to stop
her panicked breathing her only option
were to make a break for it dashing
through the forest and hope she and
Josie weren't caught or Worse killed
though these days there was really no
difference between the two or she could
wait for the MTF to pass byy continuing
their search she had spent months trying
to survive in this anomalous apocalyptic
nightmare by now the foundation couldn't
have known she was there their forces
were just combing the forest looking for
any survivors they could find but if she
stayed still there was still a chance
one of the MTF would find her and Josie
and would either alert the others or
just open fire on the spot All Things
Considered neither option sounded ideal
Josie was getting restless trying to
wriggle free of Sophie's grip that cat's
incorporeal back half meant Sophie could
only hold what little Underside the
feline friend had slowly she started to
get up and made her way out from behind
the tree right into the path of an MTF
trooper's flashlight got a live one he
yelled a flash of light and a loud bang
echoed through the forest the bullet had
torn through Sophie's chest nearly
missing her half cat but the noise of
the shot had been more than enough to
startle her as Sophie dropped to the
forest floor gripping her heavily
bleeding wound and ring in pain Josie
leaped into the air towards the
foundation operative either in shock or
because she somehow understood her
protector had been shot The Brave Little
Cat started clawing at the soldier's
face despite her sharp front claws
tearing at him leaving red lines over
his face the arm man didn't react it was
as if he couldn't feel pain at all the
MTF Trooper gripped Josie by the neck
fur pulling her away from him before he
could reach for his sidearm someone
charged at him knocking the foundation
operator over another shot rang out as
he fell tackled by Sophie meanwhile
Josie had dropped to the ground landing
on her two visible feet and hissing at
the soldier scrambling to her feet
Sophie picked up Josie and ran the
sounds of the rest of the task force
receding into the distance behind her
the little half cat was looking back
over her human friend's shoulder
watching as the sweeping flashlights of
the MTF kill Squad fanned between the
trees until they eventually disappeared
from view her earlier adrenaline Spike
began to drop sharply in time with the
gradual rise of the sun Sophie had long
since slowed down certain that she'd be
able to give the foundation's foot
soldiers the slip Josie had taken her
favorite perch on Sophie's shoulder
again meaning she could use her hands to
apply pressure to her two wounds but
with every step the former researcher
could feel her limbs getting heavier her
pulse which had drum faster than ever as
her and her half-cat had fled was now
slowing down with every fading beat she
was tired so much that she could barely
to keep her head up until eventually
Sophie had to stop she sat at the edge
of a lake in the middle of the forest
exhaustedly trying to catch her breath
calmly Josie hopped off her shoulder and
sat down at her side licking her paw and
cleaning behind her ears Sophie looked
at her little friend and smiled feeling
a tear run down her face she reached
into her bag and produced her journal
tearing out a page and squalling down a
note with the last of her strength to
whoever finds this half cat her name is
Josie she's my only friend left in the
whole world I've taken care of her for
as long as I can but I'll be dead soon
please take care of her for me take her
to safety be good to her and she'll be
good to you and if you scavenge any
cheese only give her a little as a treat
after tying the note to Josie's
midsection so it rested a top her semic
corporeal back half Sophie looked around
one last time the lake was calm a tiny
pocket of remaining peace in a world
gone mad overrun with anomalies guess we
did make it to a sanctuary after all
Josie she whispered weakly giving her
little half-cat one last scratch behind
the ears Josie meowed gratefully finally
unable to keep her eyes open and her
head up any longer Sophie cartright let
herself drift off Josie was left meowing
at her friend to wake up she sat with
her all day she didn't move didn't even
wake up when Josie nuzzled her face
against hers like she had before so
Sophie's face felt much colder now
against the confused half cat's fur
eventually Josie wandered off into the
forest towards an uncertain future maybe
if this future wasn't set in stone if it
could be reset then Josie the half cat
would see her friend Sophie again who
doesn't love dogs they're friendly
energetic and can be beneficial to their
owner's happiness and mental health on
top of all those positive qualities most
dogs are fiercely loyal to their masters
you'll often hear stories of dogs
defending their owners or even staying
by their side through their very last
days and even sticking next to them
Beyond Death as sad as that thought
might be to many dog owners it provides
us the perfect context for today's topic
it's about time you met SCP
1111 sometimes also known by the
nickname the white dog this moniker
actually refers to one of the two halves
of SCP 1111 namely the former SCP 111
11-1 while its counterpart is simply
known only as SCP 111
11-2 as you may have already deduced SCP
11-11-1 is or at least appears to be a
fairly common domesticated dog sporting
white fur that gives it its nickname the
white dog is a cross between two
different popular breeds the German
Shepherd and the labrador retriever
however upon closer inspection this
particular pup is a far cry from one you
might see fetching sticks or chasing
squirrels at the park for one this dog
never eats or drinks under normal
circumstances that would be worrying
behavior in any dog but in SCP 1111 d1's
case it comes second to the fact that
this dog is partially seethrough now
that's definitely not normal in actual
fact this Pooch is pretty far from
ordinary it seems to be at least
semi-translucent not quite as much as we
usually picture a ghost or hologram but
also not fully visible like a living
being in fact how clearly visible the
white dog is can vary depending on how
close it is to 111
11-2 any further than 500 M away and the
dog will gradually grow more and more
transparent but not fully invisible but
visibility isn't the only thing that
shifts with 1111 d1's distance from its
other half the size of the dog also
changes it remains standing at 150 CM
when Direct ly beneath 1111 D2 and
gradually gets smaller the further and
further away from 1111 D2 it gets
finally there's its eyes SCP 11-11-1
possesses a distinct pair of glowing red
eyes the brightness and intensity of
which increase the closer it is to 111
11-2 so let's recap so far we have a
strange white dog with glowing eyes that
changes size and becomes more or less
visible the further it gets from a
secondary element but if the white dog
is SCP 111 11-1 then what forms this
second part of SCP 1111 well if you were
to look close enough at the white dog
you'd notice the red collar that it
wears around its neck and hanging from
that collar is a tag on which is printed
one single word loyal it's certainly A
fitting word to describe
11-11-1 why because SCP 111 11-2 is
presumably the dog's master or rather
its Master's dead body dressed in an old
worn business suit and formal dress
shoes SCP 111 11-2 appears to be a
deceased male of indeterminate age the
precise identity of this man has proven
next to impossible for foundation
researchers to determine the condition
of his suit and shoes have deteriorated
so much that it has been difficult to
even identify the original company that
produced the clothing worn by the corpse
as for his cause of death well that
unfortunately seems all too obvious
given that the 111 11-2 body always
appears the same way hanging from a tree
with a new surround his neck Foundation
staff observed the two parts that make
up SCP 1111 have noted that 111 11-2
will occasionally make quick violent
twitching movements these random jerks
and spasms of the corpse are consistent
with those exhibited by a person who is
dying from a fixation and often
researchers have heard the body making
desperate gasps for air the closer his
white furied canine counterpart is the
more frequent and violent these motions
and sounds will become it's almost as if
SCP 111 11-2 has somehow been trapped on
the very brink of death reliving those
final moments over and over again all
while guarded by his loyal white dog if
left alone and not interfered with the
white dog will lie down just beneath
where its Master's body is hanging the
dog never sleeps nor does it require any
food or water and does not even seem to
breathe and as long as Foundation
research staff keep their distance both
parts of SCP 1111 seem contend to remain
in a docile state to keep them contained
the SCP Foundation has established a 2
km safe Zone around SCP 1111 keeping
them monitored through cameras attached
to weather balloons the restricted
enclosure is according to a public cover
story a weather monitoring station hence
the balloons no member of foundation
staff is permitted anywhere within a
kilometer of SCP 1111 unless they are
given express permission from a superior
member of the foundation should SCP
11-11-1 ever stray away from the tree
where its Master hangs though then the
area must be evacuated of all Personnel
until the dog returns to its normal
position however Foundation staff are
urged to be wary When approaching SCP
1111 because the white dog may well be
more ferociously loyal than any pet
emphasis on ferocious the the moment
that 11-11-1 becomes aware of anything
coming towards itself and its owner's
body the dog will become viciously
hostile regardless of the person or
object coming towards it the semic
corporeal canine will attempt to attack
and destroy the Intruder in this state
the white dog exhibits even more
dramatic physiological differences from
a normal domesticated dog video footage
recorded by the SCP Foundation shows
that the dog is capable of reaching
incredible speeds of up to 60 km per
hour which is of course considerably
faster than an average canine the white
dog can also reach a height of 6 M When
jumping up into the air and has teeth
and a bite strength powerful enough to
tear through armor plating composed of
15 mm thick titanium given the entity
speed aggression and translucent
qualities any attempts by the SCP
Foundation to neutralize the white dog
or even capture it for closer
examination have ended the same Grizzly
way for the staff members who tried the
the creatures Fierce loyalty defending
its owner's body also make it incredibly
difficult for foundation staff to even
get close enough to SCP 111 11-2 to
properly study the remains as we said
before that loyal tag around the dog's
neck is certainly an accurate
description on a date which has been
redacted from its file an incident
occurred involving SCP 1111 and a team
that consisted of a number of foundation
agents this team had been ordered to
neutralize the white dog and transport
the anomalous animal to a containment
facility attempting to evade the
creature's direct line of sight the
agents approached the hanging body of
SCP 111 11-2 from the north the opposite
direction to the way the dog was facing
possessing a sense of hearing and smell
far beyond that of a human being the
white dog was able to quickly detect the
agents approaching its Master when the
team got within 300 M of the tree where
the body was hanging the canine set upon
them tearing at clothing and shredding
protective armor with its teeth in order
to get the agent soft flesh underneath
one of these agents fled running as fast
as they could from the area but of
course this was audile move as the white
dog quickly noticed and began to pursue
the foundation agent with its
superpowered speed as it chased them the
surveillance cameras recorded SCP
11-11-1 decreasing in size becoming
harder to see with the naked eye the
further it ran from the tree the dog's
speed began to decline too the further
the dog got from the tree with the news
the less the body hanging from it seemed
to be spasming too when the white dog
had reached 900 M from SCP 111 11-2 the
corpse was seen to stop moving entirely
Frozen and stiff as one would normally
expect a deceased body to be realizing
how far away it was from its Master SC
CP 11-11-1 froze appearing unsure for a
moment it turned to look towards the
body of its Master perhaps sensing that
the random jerks and postmortem
movements had stopped at this point the
dog howled and sprinted back towards the
tree causing the corpse of its owner to
begin twitching yet again footage of
this incident showed that the white dog
was impervious to Conventional Weapons
and any rounds fired at the canine by
Foundation agents merely passed through
its ghostly body however its claws and
teeth were very much solid and it was
able to slaughter almost all the agents
save for the one who fled who ended up
being the sole survivor of the encounter
following this disastrous Mission the
the 05 Council issued an order that in
order to protect the lives of foundation
personnel only remote control drones and
Expendable d-class Personnel would be
permitted anywhere near SCP 1111 shortly
after the previous incident a group of
d-class were sent into the area around
the tree where SCP 111 11-2 was hanging
this time approaching from multiple
directions at once but this only led to
the same results as the white dog began
to quickly move between each of the DCL
classes killing them one one after
another only one D
83011 was able to make it close enough
to the corpse to make any noteworthy
observations as they approached the
hanging corpse of SCP 1111 D2 seemed to
slow its jerks and twitches and the body
did something that had never been seen
before it opened its eyes it raised its
arms towards the approaching d-class in
what looked like a welcoming hug only
for D
83011 to be torn to shreds by the white
dog moments after cameras nearby picked
up more previously unseen movement
namely the owner's mouth moving almost
as if he was saying the words no down
boy but soon after the corpse fell limp
again and resumed its normal Twitches
following this the foundation have
theorized that the white dog could
possibly be contained by somehow
removing its Master's body from the area
some staff have also noted that SCP 1111
shares certain traits with SCP 023 a
similar anomalous creature also referred
to to as the black Shu much like the
white dog the shook also possesses a
ghostly canine form and appears to be
the same large doglike creature that is
referenced in ancient folklore from
throughout the British Isles according
to Legend the Shu appears to Travelers
at Crossroads serving as an omen of bad
luck impending disaster and is even
thought to be one of the hounds of Hell
itself SCP 023 like SCP 1111 also has
anomalous abilities that focus on
Geographic space in the black Shuck's
case anyone it detects approaching it
will die or lose a member of their
family within a year researchers working
for the foundation believe that SCP 023
and SCP 11-11-1 could be related or even
instances of the same phenomenon a sort
of dog yin and yang but since they have
still as of yet been unable to capture
the white dog it has been impossible to
verify this the SCP Foundation will no
doubt keep trying though while testing
may have been suspended for the time
being they always know where to find SCP
11-11-1 beneath its Master's hanging
body guarding it for all eternity being
a d-class for the SCP Foundation is a
lot like playing Russian roulette one
day you could be assigned to a tickle
fight with a friendly blob of slime and
next you're getting your femurs broken
to lure a sadistic old man back into his
containment chamber so when D 9781 was
told to Simply sit in an interrogation
room and wait he really didn't know what
to think but the last thing he probably
expected to see was when the door behind
him creaked open was for A well-dressed
stranger to step in this man wasn't like
any member of foundation staff the
declass had ever seen he was a short
Caucasian man with a receding hairline
and a neat black mustache instead of the
standard lab coat and shirt normally
seen around the facility this man wore a
black waste coat a pair of white gloves
and a Ry smile that betrayed his
Sinister intent he looked like a butler
and not just any Butler but the
quintessential Butler if you were asked
to Doodle a cartoon Butler this would be
the man you drew the d-class almost
laughed in sheer confusion he had no
idea that in a mere moment he would be
dead now what's the deal Jes he asked
with a mocking half smile but he didn't
get to hear a response the butler
approached at frightening speeds the
d-class in his last moments on Earth saw
the glint of something metallic under
the overhead lights moving too fast for
him to see what it was and then felt a
sharp pain across his throat the butler
was standing beside him now still with
that Ry little smile the declass could
see now that the butler was carrying a
small buck knife dripping with red just
as he was piecing together what had
happened to him the d-class collapsed
onto the table he was sitting at his
throat expertly slit his Grizzly task
completed the butler gave a polite nod
and exited the room smiling at the
foundation guard standing outside who is
this man why is he dressed like this and
most importantly why is he allowed to
murder d-class Personnel on Foundation
grounds without consequence we can
answer that first question right now
because this isn't a man at all he's the
anomalous product of SCP
662 also known as the butler's handbell
first we need to go back to the
beginning and see how this anomalous
object first fell into the hands of the
SCP Foundation like a lot of anomalous
objects now under the care of the
foundation its true Origins remain
mysterious and it spent quite some time
Underground we mean that literally by
the way it was buried with its last
owner a man whose name has since been
redacted from Foundation files clutched
in this unknown man's skeletal hand it
was extremely likely that the Bell might
never have been seen again but then a
petty thief and gra robber by the name
of George Dixon came along and dug up
the grave a simple greedy act that has
changed a number of people's lives
forever not knowing the true value of
what he held Mr Dixon made his way to a
pawn shop for his payday there the store
owner made the mistake of lifting up and
ringing the bell as if On Queue he heard
footsteps approaching behind him the
store owner turned in gasp he saw a
complete stranger emerging from the
stock room behind him he was a short
well-dressed man smiling as he Advanced
towards him the proprietor of the pawn
shop didn't know who this guy with the
strange outfit was but he assumed he was
an accomplice of the man in his store
and that the two were trying to rob him
he grabbed a shotgun from underneath his
counter turned to the Butler and blasted
him in the chest with both barrels the
butler fell back dead and George Dixon
fled the scene in a blind panic contrary
to what the owner may have believed
nothing that happened here had been
planned Dixon was just as surprised as
he was to see this mysterious Butler
emerged from the stock room so what had
just happened the pawn shop owner
reported the incident to the authorities
and the butler's body was taken to the
local morg while the Silver Bell ended
up in a police evidence Locker later
that same night things went from a
strange bungled robbery to a fullon
anomaly attracting the attention of the
SCP Foundation First the butler's body
disappeared from the mor the second the
mortician took her eyes off of it and
then reappeared now alive in the police
storage locker why because an unwitting
Sergeant just so happened to ring the
little silver bell agent Bradford of the
SCP Foundation was promptly on the scene
he pretended to be an FBI agent and
escorted the butler off the premises
claiming that this was a notorious
escape artist who was wanted for federal
crimes in several States things didn't
go as Bradford planned though when he
discovered that the Butler had
disappeared from his handcuffs when no
one was looking agent Bradford theorized
that this had something to do with with
the bell and he confiscated it for
testing later when he rang the bell
inside an SCP Containment facility the
butler turned up once more he introduced
himself as Mr Deeds and said that he
would happily perform any service that
agent Bradford required despite being
offered the phenomenal power of a
seemingly magical Butler Bradford
politely refused the offer and instead
handed the Bell over to his superiors
but don't worry agent Bradford wasn't
left completely empty-handed and was
given the esteemed SCP Foundation pat on
the back award for performing such a
professional and selfless act in service
of the foundation the superior who ended
up with the Bell however wouldn't have
quite the same level of professionalism
but more on that later the Bell
cataloged as SCP 662 was small and made
of pure silver with no obvious anomalous
elements at face value it was a mere 4
cm tall and 2 cm wide with a small
inscription reading forever mind
sjw researchers studying the Bell also
noted that it lacked its ringer but
whenever the Bell was rung a chime would
still sound from somewhere in the room
to Signal the arrival of Mr Deeds the
anomalous Butler the object was
classified as safe and was kept in high
value storage locker 23c between uses
for experiments it's an extremely
low-maintenance anomaly with the only
real requirement being a regular polish
to keep the silver from tarnishing over
time but what of Mr Deeds the mysterious
Butler summoned every time someone Rings
SC SCP 662 the foundation needed to find
out more so he was placed under the
watchful eye of foundation researcher Dr
mirth who performed the first interview
with Mr Deeds as you can probably expect
from such a classy servant Mr Deeds was
unfailingly polite during the interview
he always addressed Dr mirth as sir and
was extremely accommodating within
reason Mr Deeds true name birthplace and
date of birth were still a mystery to
him he could only vaguely remember that
he was of English ancestry and that
during the time of his childhood the
horse and buggy were the most popular
form of Transport when asked about
personal details or his past Mr Deeds
would often appear to become distressed
before apologizing for his inability to
remember the details the most important
piece of information that Dr mirth
obtained early on in the interview was
the primary function of Mr Deeds he was
was an entity that quite literally lived
to serve like a genie being summoned
from his lamp Mr Deeds would try to
perform any task that the Summoner gave
him whether it was cooking dinner or
robbing banks there were certain limits
to these Powers though and these limits
were what Dr MTH needed to discover Dr
mirth first asked for a glass of iced
tea from Mr Deeds the butler happily
obliged and left the room walking down
the hallway while attending agents kept
their eyes on him Mr Deeds continued to
merely walk however the second they
looked away the cameras observing him
malfunctioned Deeds briefly disappeared
and then returned with a tray of iced
tea Dr MTH remarked that it was perhaps
the best iced tea he'd ever tasted Mr
Deeds couldn't recall how the tea was
made though or how he obtained it Dr
mirth next asked for a bar of gold at
99.98% Purity and Mr Deeds delivered
almost the exact level of Purity Dr
mirth asked for from this he uced that
Mr Deeds can only perform his
teleportation and manifestation
abilities when he's out of people's
direct lines of sight he soon discovered
that certain requests were off the table
though Dr mirth asked for Mr Deeds to
fetch him a blue 1963 Corvette
convertible Mr Deeds did not immediately
procure the car instead telling the
doctor that such a thing was impossible
because there were too many impractical
steps involved in getting the vehicle Dr
MTH was disappointed by this since he
really wanted that car it seemed though
as Mr de's Powers while enhanced by
teleportation and the ability to
manifest simple objects are limited by
things that a mostly normal and very
persistent person could conceivably do
for example on Dr M's orders Mr Deeds
politely declined to assassinate an
Insurgent leader in the Middle East
seeing as he was too well guarded and
very far away however when given the
command he was more than willing to head
into the next room and murder a member
of d-class with a knife Dr MTH was was
interested in getting a closer look at
what was going on with Mr ded's biology
and so asked him to slit his own throat
with the same knife he used to murder
the d-class Mr Deeds politely obliged
commenting before he did to Dr mirth
that had been an absolute pleasure
serving him the body was kept within an
agent's line of sight at all time until
the autopsy could be performed just to
make sure it didn't disappear the
autopsy showed that there was nothing
inherently anomalous about the
physiology of Mr Deeds and he would
appear as good as new the next time the
bell rang things took an even stranger
turn after that though despite it
appearing like the foundation now knew
everything they needed to know about Mr
Deeds and the SCP 662 Bell Dr mirth
insisted on performing further studies
into what exactly Mr Deeds was capable
of for example he requested a deep
tissue massage and found that it
completely cured his back pain Dr MTH
also asked Mr Deeds to clean his car and
found that it was cleaned to a truly
impeccable standard during his tenure as
the lead researcher on the 662 project
he also asked to receive a haircut from
Mr Deeds and found out that while Mr
Deeds excelled at many tasks he made a
pretty bad Barber he was great at
laundry though Dr Mir was eventually
removed from 662 Duty by the 05 Council
once it became clear his research had
just become an excuse for Mr Deeds to do
errands and chores for him of course Mr
Deeds had no complaints either way
whether it's serving up delicious tea
cleaning a certain selfish researcher's
home or murdering a d-class personnel
with a buck knife one thing cannot be
denied Mr Deeds is one hell of a butler
meet Trevor Hawthorne now known as D
4651 on the outside he was an armed
robber who murdered two people during a
convenience store shootout in Texas but
now since being condemned to death he's
been picked up for d-class testing by
the SCP found
now also meet Junior researcher Dr Julia
Reed an aspiring Foundation scientist
with an undiagnosed heart condition the
kind of heart condition that doesn't mix
well with a highpressure job at the SCP
Foundation these two woke up on the
morning of December 6th 2011 completely
unaware of the fact that they were only
hours away from causing one of the most
devastating containment breaches site 19
had seen in years many people died that
day but thankfully for everyone else SCP
131 were there to save the day when you
think of a hero you probably don't
picture a pair of little cyborgs with
one eye and the intelligence of a
household cat but this is the tale of
how two of the most unassuming anomalies
at site 19 managed to save thousands of
people from two of the site's most
dangerous inmates open your eyes and
keep them open if you so much as blink
it's all over for you how long can you
hold it difficult right now imagine
you're having a staring contest with an
entity that can kill you if you dare to
Blink for even a fraction of a second or
even worse a creature that could
potentially kill hundreds or even
thousands of people if your attention
drifts from it for any amount of time
try keeping your eyes open with that
kind of crushing pressure we're talking
about two of the most deadly euklid and
ker class anomalies out there SCP 173
the killer sculpture a violent uclid
class entity that is incapable of moving
while being looked at if ever it's
unobserved it'll snap the neck of anyone
nearby SCP 689 known as Haunter in the
dark is an equally dangerous and even
more attention demanding statue these
two entities are Beyond dangerous even
as SCP 682 is terrified of the killer
sculpture and researchers have been
considering the use of 689 to
potentially eliminate the hardto destroy
reptile for quite some time their
greatest concern though is whether the
30 cm tall statue would cause too much
collateral damage to Foundation
Personnel in the process Trevor
Hawthorne was part of the three-man
d-class detail meant to clean out SCP
173s Containment chamber at regular
intervals while on cleaning Duty two DCL
classes can keep staring at the
sculpture while the other tidies up the
cell alternating turns to Blink but that
morning Trevor had woken up in his
containment cell with a killer migraine
and soon that migraine would be killing
far more than just him the containment
procedures in 689 cell were also a
three-person job 689 is a small green
soapstone statue of a skeletal being
sitting on a throne believed to be some
form of Underworld death deity
discovered by German archaeologists in
India this is a work of religious art
that demands your attention or you and
anyone else who's ever seen this ker
class nightmare will suffer a horrifying
fate anyone who's ever seen the statue
is infected by its anomalous effects it
must be observed constantly or someone
who's seen it in the past will suddenly
drop dead of a severe health issue like
a stroke or multiple rupturing organs
like the god of death the statue
represents it appears on top of the dead
body of whoever it just killed if not
continually paid attention to it'll keep
hopping from person to person until it's
killed everyone who's ever looked at it
its teleporting abilities and the fact
that it poses a threat to so many make
this a truly formidable foe it's kept in
a constantly lit cell and is observed by
two members of d-class personnel at all
times but a crucial third party in the
containment of SCP 689 is a member of
personnel at level two or above they
remain in a control room wearing a
special visor to prevent them from ever
seeeing 689 and becoming infected
themselves if the containment fails it's
their job to throw the kill switch on
The d-class Observers to prevent them
from becoming vectors for infection
today this job fell on Dr Julia Reed she
was linked to the two observers via an
audio feed allowing her to remain in
constant contact with them and she had
her finger on the activation key for a
pair of explosive collars that were
around the d-class is necks little did
they know Dr Reed's heart was its own
time bomb now you know what we're up
against a snap happy sculpture and a
teleporting death statue with a Hit List
containing everyone who's ever glanced
at it what can s CP 131 bring to the
table the two small cycloptic anomalies
have only one remarkable ability they
never blink that and a soft spot for
humans these safe class scps pose no
threat to their handlers and can even
form attachments to researchers and
other staff who show affection towards
them of course forming these bonds is
discouraging by site 19's director
because it can be distracting but that
doesn't mean it doesn't happen the two
iPods known as SCP 131a and SCP 131b are
identical in appearance except for their
colors a is a burnt orange and B is a
mustard yellow the two of them appear to
communicate with one another via
high-pitch squeaking noises and also
seem to have an innate ability to detect
danger occurring in the vicinity as well
as danger occurring near individuals
they've bonded with because of their
inability to cause harm and their
generally affectionate demeanor the
iPods are allowed to roam around site 19
provided they keep out of the way of
researchers and stay out of restricted
areas they seem to pretty much stick to
the rules though check-ins On A and B
are required every hour just to be safe
as the iPods were moving freely around
the facility Trevor and another d-class
maintained a visual on the sculpture in
its containment chamber while a third
man swept up the mixture of blood and
excrements staining the concrete floors
things were going fine until Trevor's
migraine got the better of him a sudden
flash of intense pain shot through his
head and in a moment of weakness he made
a terrible mistake with an audible groan
of pain Trevor closed his eyes and
forced his fingers to his temples the
groan had taken his fellow Observer off
guard and the Man's eyes flitted over to
him for a fraction of a second but a
fraction of a second is all the
sculpture needs in an instant Trevor and
his his fellow Watcher had their necks
snapped and the third d-class was
murdered before he even had a chance to
turn around containment protocol
dictates that the door is to be sealed
behind the cleaning crew while they're
working with 173 but this time perhaps
due to complacency the guards had
neglected to reinforce the door they got
their heads Twisted 180° for their
trouble SCP 173 was loose mobile task
forces were dispatched to Aid in the
recontainment effort as 173 began
wrecking Havoc around the facility but
things were about to get even worse it
seemed like business as usual over at
the containment cell of SCP 689 two DCL
classes observed while Dr Reed dictated
to them over an earpiece from her
control center however what Dr re
thought were just minor chest pains were
actually the onset of heart failure when
the two DCL classes heard their
supervisor experiencing a fatal heart
attack on the other end of the line they
began to panic this meant their
attention wasn't entirely on SCP 689 and
they were further distracted by the
chaos SCP 173 was causing elsewhere in
the facility murdering researchers
guards and maintenance workers alike
which led to power outages the lights in
689s containment cell shut down guards
were dispatched to execute The Observers
as is protocol for 689 containment
breaches but the fact that resources
were already stretched thin by the 173
breach caused a fatal error in judgment
from a guard posted nearby in a panic he
opened the door to find one d-class dad
with the statue perched on his body and
the other one running straight for him
in blind fear the two collided and
tumbled out into the hall both were now
infected by 689s anomalous attention and
both were now doomed moments later the
two of them were dead the statue perched
on their bodies accidentally catching
the eye of several researchers and
guards running to deal with the 173
situation for these two deadly anomalies
it was becoming an all you can kill
Buffet the staff of site 19 were now
dealing with one anomaly that needed to
be looked at constantly and another that
if you even glance at it you are
effectively infected with a fatal
disease the iPods sensing an imminent
danger nearby immediately sprung into
action it would be up to these cute
harmless anomalies to save the terrified
staff during this chaotic double
Containment Breach in a nearby Hall away
a fleeing Foundation researcher heard
the crunches of her colleagues necks
breaking behind her 173 was getting
closer this thing couldn't be outrun she
turned and saw the statue standing there
just 10 ft away from her a dead
researcher laying on the ground in front
of it she was locked in a deadly staring
contest with the sculpture how long she
could survive was now dependent on how
long she could keep her eyes open and it
was getting harder by the second she
could feel her eyes drying they burned
under the ceiling lights 173 just waited
this wasn't a contest she could win in a
final moment of Terror the researcher
was forced to finally close her eyes and
she waited for the crunch but it never
came instead she heard familiar
high-pitch squeaking noises she opened
her eyes crying tears of relief as she
saw SCP 131a sitting behind 173 watching
it with its constant unblinking gaze the
the killer sculpture was paralyzed by a
cheerful little safe class anomaly
across the facility a similar situation
had unfolded with SCP 689 the statue of
death had claimed many lives but SCP
131b had swooped in and Frozen the
statue in place with its NeverEnding
gaze soon after a mobile task force with
vision blocking visors used Advanced
echolocation technology to collect SCP
689 and return it to its containment
cell everyone who'd seen the anomaly was
as standard protocol dictates gathered
up for later termination meanwhile a
mobile task force returned the paralyzed
173 back to its containment cell with a
forklift no Containment Breach is ever a
picnic containment breaches with
multiple dangerous anomalies are even
less so but the heroic role that SCP 131
played in bringing things back under
control was indispensable after all it's
not just raw power that counts when it
comes to an anomalies the only anomalous
power 131 needed to save the entire site
was its ability to keep looking when
nobody else could they're so effective
in this role that they've been seriously
considered for permanent roles as
wardens for scps like 173 and 689 and in
our opinion they're more than qualified
a terrified man huddles in the corner
heart pounding and teeth chattering he
sees them coming towards him huge
eight-legged figures years 10 ft tall at
least with eight black soulless eyes
that seem to stare hungrily at him it's
like something out of a nightmare giant
man eating spiders everywhere they
approach the man fangs dripping with
Venom but just as they're about to
strike he vanishes he won't be spider
food today but for this truly unlucky
guy his ordeal is far from over let's
rewind when life gets a little too
boring we all daydream about getting
away maybe you imagine sitting on a
tropical beach or camping in the
mountains and breathing in the fresh air
some of the more adventurous types with
a vivid imagination might daydream about
visiting a parallel universe who
wouldn't want the chance to see what
life is like in another dimension of
course it would only be fun to go there
if you could control where you went and
when you could come back without any
control over it the ability to hop back
and forth between Dimensions would turn
from a blessing to a curse just ask SCP
sc507 unlike most other scps is a
seemingly normal human man he has blonde
hair green eyes an unrecognizable accent
and no other features that might make
him stand out he looks perfectly average
Like a Stranger you'd pass on the street
and never give a second thought to what
sets him apart is not a physical
attribute
but rather an ability that he has yet to
develop a firm grasp on he is a
dimension Hopper with no control over
where he goes or when he'll get back
after appearing on the grounds of a
mental treatment facility with no
identification rambling about a world of
giant spiders SCP 507 was admitted to
the hospital and sedated for his own
safety he would spend several months in
treatment for a variety of supposed
disorders but once he became aware of
his surroundings he attempted to escape
the hospital multiple times during these
Escape attempts he often alluded
Hospital staff by mysteriously
disappearing and reappearing in
seemingly impossible places such as
behind locked doors or in rooms blocked
off from the rest of the hospital these
disappearances and reappearances seem to
be contrary to what the hospital staff
first believed Beyond his control the
SCP Foundation became a aware of the
strange phenomena surrounding 507 and he
was removed from the hospital and
brought to an SCP Foundation facility
once there the nature of his abilities
became much clearer SCP 507 is able to
without intent or even knowledge that it
is about to occur shift from this
reality to another alternate reality
after sometime there with the amount of
time varying from case to case he will
shift back to this reality he has been
known to shift realities while sleeping
in the middle of a sentence and even
while bathing or going to the bathroom
the shifts are unpredictable and there
is no telling what kind of Horrors he
will encounter in the new dimension
where he ends up leading to 507 having
seen some very strange things even bya
CP Foundation standards during one of
his shifts 507 found himself in a pitch
black room filled with the sound of
muted breathing using a flashlight he
had been given by the foundation he
looked around and found that he was not
alone in the room with him was a man
wearing a black suit and sunglasses with
a frightening inhumanly wide smile The
Smiling man leaned in towards 507 so
close that their faces nearly touched
and said back so soon terrified 507
fired several rounds from a foundation
issued pistol then curled up in the
corner of the room until he shifted back
to our room reality this would not be
the last time that he encountered The
Smiling man according to document 5073 B
which details all of 507 shifts into
other realities 507 was found in a
Midwestern cornfield by Foundation staff
with brown liquid on his cheek in his
hand he held a human heart with the
words I need you written on it in the
same brown liquid before he shifted back
and landed in the cornfield 507 shifted
to a black room filled with the sound of
muffled crying he turned on his
flashlight taking note of his
surroundings and found himself face to
face with the smiling man once again The
Smiling man had brown liquid leaking
from around its sunglasses which it
wiped onto 507s cheek upon further
examination 507 saw several bullet holes
in The Smiling Man's suit leaking the
same brown liquid he attempted to fire
his pistol like he had the previous time
but it did not fire as The Smiling man
began to approach him 507 turned and ran
he ran for about 10 minutes before
finding a corner where he stayed huddled
once again until he shifted Back The
Smiling man is not the only nightmare
that SCP 507 has encountered on his
travels during another shift 507
described appearing in a small room
filled with dried corpses a single
window and a flickering light hanging
from a ceiling while attempting to wait
out his time in the room he discovered
that the corpses were capable of
movement whenever the room was in
darkness the corpses would pose
themselves like living people when he
looked out the window the corpses would
join him and look out the window with
him when he sat down they would sit with
him in the circle 507 attempted to pass
time by falling asleep but was unable to
do so though many of his experiences
were disturbing only one of 507s
documented shifts resulted in him
requesting a memory wipe from the SCP
Foundation on this one he found himself
in the maternity wing of a large
Hospital a creature dressed like a nurse
approached 507 and told him that he was
upsetting the other patients and that it
was time to start the operation 507 was
then wrapped in the straight jacket and
wheeled into an operating room after the
straight jacket was taken off 57 grabbed
a chair and swung it wildly at the
creatures to keep them at Bay until he
shifted back when he asked to describe
the appearance of the nurse creature 507
began screaming in Terror and was unable
to provide a coherent description he
attempted to provide a drawing of the
creature but was only able to produce a
series of jagged lines following this
encounter his request for a memory wipe
was denied other shifts included going
to a world where every surface was
covered with an unidentifiable mold a
land of icy Tundras populated by
aggressive bears and one place place
that he refused to describe Beyond
repeating the phrase so many spiders not
all of the worlds that 507 has
encountered are frightening some are
simply strange and unusual during one
shift he found himself on a large
basketball court where six other
individuals were playing a game of
basketball there were two humans two
insectoid creatures one creature
resembling a squid and one hovering
yellow sphere with eight arms when 507
asked where he was he was informed that
he had arrived at the Alles Sports
Center during another shift 507 found
himself in a world made entirely of
gelatin during yet another shift he
appeared in a large Auditorium filled
with 50,000 other dimension Hoppers who
were holding a political Rally For The
People's Dimension Hopper Republic
working with the Republic over the
course of 2 weeks 507 helped to
overthrow the United States government
and establish a new one run by Dimension
Hoppers SC SCP 507 was elected
representative of Massachusetts but just
before he could introduce his first
official piece of legislation he shifted
back to our reality one day at the
facility a particularly unusual event
involving SCP 507 occurred the events of
which were documented in interview
507-b during a regular check-in it was
discovered that there were somehow two
identical versions of SCP 5 07 in its
room they had apparently each arrived in
the room independently and had been
talking to one another for about half an
hour before being discovered these two
versions were referred to as 507 a and
507-b when prompted for an explanation
507-b explained that there were more
than one version of SCP 507 Afflicted
with uncontrollable Dimension hopping
the doctor inquired as to which one of
the two was the visitor but the two
declined to answer fearing that this
knowledge would cause the foundation to
view one of them as Expendable the two
had multiple shared experiences that
they related to the doctor including
both having encounters with the smiling
man during the interview 507-b
disappeared mids sentence and did not
reappear the doctor asked 507a about
identifiable differences between his and
his Devil's realities 507a explained
that in 507 DB's World President Lincoln
was killed by his vice president whereas
in 507 A's world he was killed by
General Lee this Revelation made it
clear that neither 507 d a nor
507-b were native to this reality after
this was revealed 57- a was terminated
and examined no biological reason for
507 ability to hop from Dimension to
Dimension was found though it was
discovered that several pieces of 507
will shift Dimensions along with the
rest of the body 3 days after this
interview was conducted the correct SCP
507 reappeared with no knowledge of his
doppelgangers or what became of them SCP
507 is classified as safe meaning he
doesn't require any real effort to
contain he's also safe in the more
literal sense in that he poses no threat
to anyone else the only person in danger
in the presence of SCP 507 is himself as
he has been exposed to many Danger
conditions during his reality shifts and
it's never known whether 507s next shift
will end up being his last with the
cause of his shift still being unknown
there is nothing that the foundation can
do to prevent them all they can do is
monitor him and provide him with the
items that might ensure his safety in
the future like a handgun loaded with
rubber bullets a tank of air a
high-intensity flashlight a week of
ration packs a pair of binoculars a
track tracking caller and a camera the
tracking caller allows the foundation to
recover 507 when he shifts back to our
reality in a location other than the
containment facility the rest of the
equipment was granted at his request
based on obstacles that he encountered
in other dimensions due to his docile
nature 507 is given freedom to move
about the facility but when he leaves
his private room an agent must go with
him to document any shifts that might
occur no one is allowed to touch SCP 507
though if it has been more than 2 weeks
since a shift occurred this policy stems
from an incident in which an agent who
was touching 507 shoulder at the time of
a shift was taken with him and did not
return when he is not shifting SCP 507
lives a relatively normal life at the
facility he is allowed his own computer
with internet access and can meet with
other safe or uclid class scps that are
not infectious or detrimental to his
health 507 has expressed an interest in
the unusual and paranormal and has
enjoyed meeting with other scps
including a request to visit SCP 082 for
a vacation so far all of these meetings
have occurred without incident due to
his anomalous shifting SCP 507 will
never be able to live a normal life
unless he stops shifting he will likely
spend the rest of his days bouncing
between unknown dimensions and his
containment facility just like so much
else about him his relationship to his
special talent is a bit of a paradox he
has the ability to go anywhere to see
things no other person on Earth has ever
seen however because he cannot control
it cannot stop it no matter how far away
he can travel he will never truly be
free some of the anomalies the SCP
Foundation deals with are dangerous with
the most powerful able to end all life
and even reality as we know it others
pose no threat at all and seem content
to Simply exist still others are
something else entirely SCP 4999 is a
humanoid entity though its appearance
seems to fluctuate between
manifestations with the only unchanging
detail being that it always is dressed
in dark formal Weare originally thought
by many to be an urban legend local
Tales of SCP 4999 are what initially
tipped the foundation off to its
existence and F Research indicates that
there are accounts that may be referring
to the appearances of 4999 throughout
recorded history strangest of all though
is the consistency with which it appears
or rather the consistent situations and
types of people it appears to from the
data available it seems that SCP 4999
only appears to people in a very
specific type of need as you'll see in
the case of a subject named Alex hord
and the Fateful night he experienced the
road was slippery and Alex was driving
driving too fast he knew this of course
but it's a different matter altogether
to know a thing and to care about it
rain hammered on the front windshield
the weak headlights of his 2005 Honda
Civic barely punching into the thick
black knight ahead of him winding
through the mountain side the road was
mostly empty save for the very
occasional twin beams of light blazing
past him due to his high speed it was
hard to hear the honking of angry horns
over the heavy pounding of the rain then
it happened in a way Alex knew knew it
was inevitable his tread warn Wheels
finally lost contact with the ground
thick layer of rainwater between them
and asphalt betraying his speeding
vehicle's grip on the road and sending
it kening out of control he had expected
fear but instead felt nothing really a
slight sense of anticipation like
wincing right before a punch lands in
that childhood game of hitting each
other on the arm it wasn't that the
world had slowed down but perhaps his
brain was simply working at a much
greater velocity now recognizing its own
impending death his speed of thought
seemed magnified to the point of slowing
his perception down he heard of soldiers
in war zones experiencing the same
phenomenon as they felt sure that in the
next few seconds they'd be dead Alex
Wonder would he smash into a tree go off
a Cliff's Edge he could hardly see the
forest or the terrain Beyond in the
thick rain and the Dark of the mountain
though he traveled this road a million
times before he had no idea where he
actually was tonight he supposed it
wouldn't really matter which it was as
usual his thoughts turned to her or
rather they had simply run their course
and returned to the one place they
always did it wasn't like there were
many other people to think about in
Alex's mostly empty life there was and
always had been since the moment he'd
met her mostly just her but even Alex's
heightened State of Mind couldn't delay
the inevitable for long it would be a
cliff after all Alex thought curiously
catching a glimpse of town lights far
away and below the car spun 180° out
into empty air Then Came Crashing Down
with a horrible Roar of shattered glass
and tearing metal as it tumbled down the
hillside even over the torrential
downpour the noise of Alex's crash was
significant had anyone been around to
hear it finally after over 100 ft down a
steep incline the car smashed into a
single thick oak tree bringing the
disaster to an end as if on Q the rain
began to let up slowly at first then all
of the sudden in that peculiar way that
Northwest torrential downpours tend to
do as if the sky had at last finished
emptying itself all at once inside the
shattered vehicle Alex was incredibly
alive at least for the time being the
airbag deployment had spared his face
the worst of it and the sturdy aluminum
frame of the vehicle had given its all
in protecting Alex's body from the
downhill crash but even postmodern
vehicle engineering had its limits his
breath came in in slow ragged gasps
difficult at first but gradually
steadying not an improvement in his
condition but rather his body dedicating
the rapidly dwindling resources at its
disposal into keeping vital functions
going as long as possible opening his
eyes Alex was surprised to find himself
right side up less surprised to look
down at the shattered mess his Limbs and
lower body had become gradually Alex's
thoughts cleared his sense of self
returning after the bone jarring Dro
down the Steep incline and sudden stop
at the end looking to his right he could
see the trunk of the tree that had
stopped his out ofc control tumble
despite himself Alex laughed a weak
gurgling chuckle so it was the cliff and
a tree after all he focused on breathing
letting the waves of pain wash over him
until his brain eventually canel them
out by injecting his broken body with
adrenaline and chemicals everything was
quiet and still after the crash and the
rain but to his surprise
he could hear something it was faint at
first just a soft crunch of footsteps on
gravel but the sound grew louder and
louder until at last it came to a stop
outside Alex's window with every ounce
of effort Alex turned his head towards
the sound a rescuer no impossible nobody
was up on this mountain and nobody could
possibly have reached him here so
quickly even if there had been he
supposed he should have been surprised
yet almost from the moment that his eyes
fell on the tall handsome figure with a
casual yet fashionably cut black suit
Alex accepted him for what he was there
was no shock no confusion for the second
time tonight just a calm sense of
acceptance the man probably somewhere in
his mid-30s leaned down to peer in
through the window he said nothing as he
casually observed the extent of Alex's
injuries satisfied he laid a hand on
Alex's shoulder the grip was firm but
not painfully so just strong enough to
communicate I am here with you things
will be all right after a slight squeeze
the figure reached inside his jacket and
produced a pack of cigarettes packing
the tobacco with swift Taps against his
palm before removing two cigarettes and
offering one to Alex Alex nodded his
head a very small motion that exploded
pain across his shattered body no thank
you but that stuff will kill you Alex
smiled the man paused for a moment the
ghost of a smile showing on his face for
just a moment before disappearing
returning the offered cigarette the man
took his own and lit it giving Alex a
good look at his face in the light of
his cigarette lighter Alex had been
right the man appeared to be somewhere
in his mid to late 30s handsome but not
cover model so just pleasing to the eyes
he sported short hair carefully combed
and perfectly neat completely unaffected
by the slight drizzle that still fell
the more Alex looked at him though the
less he could remember about the man's
exact features it wasn't that they
changed in any way but rather that he
simply couldn't hold on to any details
for more than a few seconds I'm dying
aren't I the figure didn't speak nor did
it nod or make any form of verbal or
bodily communication he simply looked
and Alex understood Alex had never been
particularly religious or spiritual but
in that look he understood that there
was a world Beyond and one that he would
very quickly be entering into it was as
if for the first time in his life he was
able to probe that world reality peeling
away just enough to Glimpse what was
beyond twisting paths through Plains of
Shadow and light both shuffling figures
along each and at the very center of it
all a light no a feeling love pulsing
forth like the Beating Heart of it all
the saints had their Angels the wicked
their demons but everyone else in
between the two they had him a guide
someone to watch over them on their
final Journey Alex coughed it was was
ending soon the man took a drag from his
cigarette and removed a handkerchief
from another hidden Pocket carefully
dabbing away the blood around Alex's
chin then returned to his silent smoking
his vision was beginning to dim around
the edges the noises of the forest
growing more and more distant Alex knew
it wouldn't be long now but he had just
one final thing to do as he always knew
they would his thoughts returned to her
here at the end once more he turned his
head towards the passenger side sea pain
exploding across his body with the
motion there just on the far edge of the
seat as his phone having miraculously
survived the crash it was no good though
even if he'd been able to move his
shattered right arm he could never reach
it with his fading strength the smoking
man took one final pull of his cigarette
putting it out on the side of the
vehicle and pocketing the stub then he
reached through the broken driver's side
window Alex catching a slight whiff of
cigarette smoke blended with an
unrecognizable but Pleasant cologne the
the man reached across Alex and grabbed
the phone pulling back and looking down
at Alex's shattered right hand after a
moment he reached down once more and put
the phone in Alex's left hand thank you
the words were barely a whisper he had
to concentrate now willing the pressing
Darkness to part just long enough for
one final task the man once more placed
his hand reassuringly on Alex's shoulder
and the Darkness parted slightly just
enough for what Alex needed to do he
worked the phone awkwardly with his left
hand gritting his teeth through the pain
of broken fingers opening a new message
he scrolled down his contacts G H I J
finally K he found her name at last then
began typing out a message I still think
about you every time it rains he moved
his thumb to press sen but that's when
Alex's body failed him at last the phone
tumbling out of his grasp but the man
was there to catch it moving blindly
fast he snatched the falling phone up
and held it carefully to Alex's eyes
before pressing sent he held the phone
there for Alex to see through his fading
Vision until at last message sent
confirmed successful delivery the rain
began once more temperamental as it
always is in the Pacific Northwest fat
heavy raindrops fell on the scene of a
terrible accident the victims seemingly
having died on impact on his lap though
lay his phone and somewhere far away and
far far below this dark Mountain Side a
message notification chirped on a
distant phone SCP 4999 manifests to only
one person at a time and only when they
are alone all subjects to date have been
in the final stages of a terminal
illness suffering from a
life-threatening injury or otherwise on
their deathbed it also appears that all
subjects have personalities and lives
that could be described as nondescript
insignificant or otherwise unremarkable
no testing of SCP 4999 has been
authorized by the foundation due to both
the difficulty in predicting where it
will appear as well as the fact that
observation seems to prevent the anomaly
from appearing there are also ethical
concerns since many in the foundation
feel that SCP 4999 is providing an
important service to humanity even if it
is only for those on the margins of
society and it is debated whether this
should be one anomalous creature that is
allowed to continue its existence and
its work without interference you're a
child awake at night what a feeling in
your room you cling to these rare hours
of the evening and watch the hour hand
crawl closer towards the parts of the
clock you've never seen touched now you
stare out your window embracing the moon
the stars and the Darkness that engulfs
them you trace an owl's hooh hoos up
towards the densest Evergreen in the
neighborhood you see a rat Scurry across
the top of a brick wall you wave to your
new nocturnal friends bonded by the
preference of night now you open your
window and inhale smelling the dark sky
like chocolate cake you hold it in as
long as you can very soon you know it
will all be taken from you not by a God
or a black hole or any of the universe's
hypothesized collapses at this age you
know nothing of physical cosmology you
know nothing of the Book of Revelation
you're just a child the for es that give
and take from you are not understood
through physics nor philosophy nor
through numbers nor thought experiments
look at you your thumb is still pruned
from having just kicked the habit of
sucking it your pajamas are still one
unified piece of clothing cradling your
entirety with fuzzy cotton your teddy
bear is still an extension of your arm
not yet removed by maturity you're still
another 15 years from believing your
life is dictated by astrological signs
or personal free will or mathematical
outputs it's not that you're ignorant in
fact you're quite bright as a child you
don't bother to comprehend the forces
outside your house because you know as
long as you are living inside it they
have no governance the only true comes
from within from the two Gods you have
seen with your very own eyes sitting on
the ripped sofa in Gray sweatpants
watching a show about rich people
drinking mimosas on boats in the
Mediterranean
the almighty parents rulers of
everything and with just one compound
word called up the stairs they have the
power to take everything away from you
bedtime and suddenly the curtains are
pulled over the world you long for now
it's not the stars but the ceiling
you're staring at but thankfully You are
not alone you pull your teddy bear out
from its hibernation beneath your armpit
and you hug him gently careful not to
squeeze out his stuffing laying there
you can't help but wonder how your bear
got like this so beaten and bruised torn
up like a dog toy one eye dangling from
a string his left leg bends forward
impersonating The Joint structures of a
flamingo yet as far as you know your
best pal has done nothing but sleep how
is he so battered can hibernation be
that taxing do teddy bears expire the
questions for now must be ignored you
lay there together in your bed fighting
the feelings of Slumber almost as if
rebelling against Mom and Dad's tyranny
thinking deeply only makes you sleepier
and tonight you insist on staying awake
it's 9:30 and you've yet to be sucked
into a dream and that in itself is a
small victory but your parents wishes
will not be evaded that easily if ever
they fight back by turning on the air
conditioning the soft rhythmic humming
of the White Noise weighs on your eyes
and soon you can't resist it any longer
sleep sneaks up on you the Battle Is
Lost a safe 10 minutes later your
parents poke their heads into your room
and see your body stiff and motionless
wrapped in sheets like a mummy they
celebrate their Victory with a quick
kiss and go back to the sofa to rest
like Gods on the seventh day and While
You Were Sleeping dreaming of a tomorrow
where you don't surrender to the same
Powers there is yet another battle to be
fought and if all goes well you'll sleep
right through it but some children won't
be so lucky un July 7th 2001 a Portland
Oregon news headline reported a young
boy missing from home in the middle of
the night his parents were quick to
respond that their son wasn't the type
of boy to go wandering out into the dark
and that something suspicious was sure
to be discovered there in his bedroom
the first thing noticed was his stuffed
animal a jovial Orca torn to shreds its
stuffing scattered across the carpet its
head and body were stationed in the
corner nearest the bed soaked in a black
substance similar to Ink its eyes damp
with water the boy however was not to be
found as the parents held their son's
dismantled Orca in their hands feeling
the weight of mortality they comb their
fingers through the stuffed animals
organs as if giving it an impromptu
autopsy trying to determine what kind of
Beast could have done this but it wasn't
Justice for the Orca they were after by
the time we are old enough to be parents
we've outgrown empathy for our inanimate
counterparts for them the orode was
simply a representation of the cruel
that may have also been bestowed on
their child its death was only respected
for how it related to the living and so
the poor Oro was set aside forgotten
about until investigators called upon
the foundation to intervene at which
point MTF Iota 12 were dispatched it
revealed that the young boy's room had
large Trails of viscous black liquid
streaking the walls the very same liquid
found on the Orca but where did this
liquid come from unfortunately there was
no camera footage to give us the answer
neither were there eyewitness reports or
any residual signs of what specifically
occurred neighbors who were awake
reported hearing the Thump Thump
thumping from the room which as expected
was useless by standard Insight leading
to nothing more than a series of rumors
and speculations maybe it was an
extremely localized earthquake maybe he
was just throwing a temper tantrum but
where does maybe this maybe that lead us
to can factual answers ever come from
this level of uncertainty
well one specific maybe just maybe the
key to cracking this case allow me to
explain 2 days after the event the child
was rediscovered unconscious behind a
hedge in the family's Garden a brief
interview revealed that the child
witnessed the final minutes of what he
described as an intense battle he
claimed my Orca was fighting a big
monster and then the monster grabbed me
and took me out the window but someone
saw it so it dropped me and I hid in the
bush a second interview revealed no
other discoveries but the child claimed
that the monster ate his socks initial
reactions to the two interviews were as
expected adults reason the claims were
imaginary a fabrication of the child's
mind manifested to protect himself from
whatever the real trauma endured
actually was but heard beneath the
skeptical murmurs of jaded grown-ups
enslaved by their narrow perceptions was
one individual who dared to suggest
maybe just maybe the boy is telling the
truth truth and it was in the spirit of
this hopeful and trusting maybe that the
foundation would prove the boy's story
to be truth and the truth would be known
as SCP
6330 SCP 6330 is a phenomenon affecting
stuffed animals worldwide though it is
most common in teddy bears manifestation
of this phenomenon is referred to as a
sleepwalker event occurring only within
the households of families with young
children typically between the ages of 1
to 14 while you're you're asleep
vulnerable to what lingers awake your
favorite stuffed animal may find life
impulsively combating enemies referred
to as SCP
63302 these creatures typically blend
with shadows though this mechanism is
poorly understood they somewhat resemble
creatures associated with fantasy such
as dragons or ogres always manifesting
beneath your bed no matter how messy or
clean it might be SCP 63302 instances
depict beh Behavior indicating that they
intend to hurt or prey upon the sleeping
child and it isn't nightlights or
security systems that stop them but
rather SCP 6330 d1s SCP 63301 are
stuffed animals already present in a
child's room that seemed to be
nonanomalous prior to SCP
63302 manifestations SCP 63301 has been
shown to instantaneously manifest small
wooden Weaponry in order to combat SC CP
6330 D2 to protect their child battles
have been shown to last upwards of 20
minutes and are always near silent there
is an unspoken agreement between both
sides to keep their history concealed as
best as they can in observed cases SCP
63301 have emerged Victorious though are
severely wounded during the Skirmish
torn wool and stuffing are common and
following all known events SCP 63301
have died due to their injuries but only
after sacrificing themselves for the
safety of the child prior to death the
instance will drag the SCP 6330 d2's
corpse back under the bed frame and Dem
manifest to understand this the
foundation has conducted just one test
given the volatile nature of recreating
the events the foundation did not push
their luck with subsequent studies and
so it's the lone research done in 1987
on site 44 that they still lean on to
this day to understand SCP 6330 and the
instances that come with it it began
with a researcher volunteering his
7-year-old daughter henceforth referred
to as subject to be placed in a humanoid
containment room and soothed to sleep
using a teddy bear that she had a strong
emotional attachment to for 12 straight
tests our subject was observed to sleep
through the night peacefully her
environment remaining in alignment with
the trivialities of deep sleep but on
the 13th study something would happen
something very unsettling even for the
foundation standards MTF Iota 12 were
stationed at the room's entrance for
Swift intervention if needed and until
that 13th attempt they felt their focus
to be pointless approaching the third
hour however they felt a subtle and
unexplained value in their presence they
felt something coming on that feeling
while danger is looming that feeling
that makes you clench your fists just in
case and just as they made eye contact
with one another to acknowledge this
shared feeling within the group a quiet
rustling sound Was Heard beneath the bed
and sounds reminiscent of a large
animals breathing became audible
suddenly a pair of large scaly clawed
hands grasped the rim of the bed frame a
creature resembling a western Dragon
emerged but was it actually a dragon
were the sheets ready to be blasted to
flames if slain would the next regrow
and multiply by the hundreds these
thoughts raced through MTF Iota 12's
head one member instinctually ran for
the door to go protect the child but he
was held back and restrained reminded
that the success of the experiment was
dependent on letting the situation play
out naturally it was hard to console
patience at this moment did not feel
like a virtue it felt irresponsible a
creature standing approximately 3 m
above the ground switching between
bipedal and quadrapedal motion was
stalking a sleeping child and they were
instructed to Simply watch for 5 minutes
the the SCP 6330 D2 patrolled the room
moving silently and methodically unaware
of the surveillance cameras then SCP
63302 turned towards the subject
positioning itself at the foot of the
bed stretching its arms out towards the
subject it gaped its jaws wide exposing
rows of large pointed teeth and a dark
pink tongue it looked like a snake in a
field of mice as it prepared to Lunge at
the subject MTF Iota 12 was ready to
intervene but before they could the
stuffed bear stood up on the subject's
chest and Drew a small sword and shield
from an unknown source almost magically
like switching weapons in an old Zelda
video game it positioned its swords tip
downward and held its Shield at its side
SCP 63301 hunched over slightly and
twirled its sword maintaining eye
contact with SCP
63302 the entire way through after 10
seconds the SCP 63302 threw its jaws at
the subject and SCP 63301 responds with
a leap towards the subject's attacker
slicing SCP 6330 d2's eye the SCP 6330
D2 responds with a quiet Grunt and
touches its wound which leaks a viscous
black liquid the SCP 63301 jumps towards
SCP
63302 and mid battle uses fabric from
the bed sheets to quickly Stitch the
wound attempting to minimize mess and
proof of its presence both instances
went to battle for 9 minutes before the
first signs of damage to SCP
63301 following the severing of one of
SCP 6330 d2's dorsal spikes it strikes
the SCP 63301 with a heavy slap which
sends SCP
63301 across the room it stands back up
placing a hand on its stomach and looks
at its hand which is now covered in wool
and stuffing they charge at each other
once again but as the subject moves
slightly in or sleep both instances stop
and quickly agree on peace until the
subject settles when that happens the
instances resume fighting research notes
that while the battle is genuine there
is an element of guidance they do not
follow a script but it appears they
follow a code while both anomalies
welcome the conflict brought on by the
other neither wants it broadcasted to
the public after 20 minutes of battle
both instances are heavily scarred and
injured after kicking itself off of the
SCP 6 6330 d2's NOS SCP 63301 Sprints
from one side of the room towards SCP
63302 leaping into the air and Landing a
fatal blow slicing the neck of the other
instance which Falls lifeless to the
floor SCP 63302 is dragged by the SCP
63301 back under the bed a short while
later the SCP 63301 emerges damage
sustained includes loss of one buttoned
eye exposed stuffing and torn wool it
places its sword and broken shield on a
nearby nightstand SCP
63301 then drags itself up the bed
sheets towards the subject who is
sleeping peacefully throughout the test
it rests beside the child lying
motionless it seems to glare directly at
the camera and a small digit protrudes
from its round hand giving a thumbs up
to the researchers its head flops onto
the child's cheek before it ceases to
move the father who rised his daughter
for research is pleased with the
discoveries regarding both anomalies but
it brings about a new set of questions
concerning children and their
relationship with the dark these very
thoughts you might even wonder yourself
maybe a kid's desire to stay up past
bedtime isn't so much about wanting to
watch cartoons with curse words or read
Calvin and Hobs maybe it's not about a
desire to be awake at all but rather a
subconscious fear of being asleep maybe
our senses as children are heighten to
the anomalies that creep about maybe all
the fabled fears of children aren't
fairy tales after all and maybe Mom and
Dad checking under our bed is just
performance parenting because even if
something were there would they even be
able to see it or is everything Beyond
an adult's understanding misattributed
to the imagination as we age does our
perception of how reality should look
alter the reality that is actually there
do we indeed see clear with our
expensive glass from our high-rise
office space or did we see more
accurately in the glow of our action
figure NightLight spying through
stitches in our blankets looking past
crusty eye boogers at what moved in the
shadows it is hard to ever know for
every real encounter a child has with an
SCP 6330 there might be hundreds of
falsehoods the ratio is truly impossible
to calculate but as long as teddy bears
are Universal so too are their anomalous
enemies and so where does that fact lead
us how do we go forward should we be
afraid to put our children to sleep
afraid of the monsters under their bed I
don't think that's what our hero would
want sometimes we have to learn to trust
things even if we don't understand them
like gravity or multiplication we have
to trust that the relationship between
children and their stuffed animals are
in fact real we have to learn their
loyalty is reciprocated even if the
adult world has taught us otherwise and
if we ever need a reminder of these
lessons we can look to event 184 in
Cambridge England where we have our
first recording of a sleepwalker event
outside of controlled testing and also
our first piece of evidence proving SCP
63301 to understand language and how to
use it to connect with humans in ways
Beyond being cute and cuddly on November
11th 2008 a call was filed to local
authorities by a family who claimed to
have discovered footage of a a
sleepwalker event within their son's
room mobile task force Iota 12 lucid
dreamers were dispatched to investigate
immediately the footage was seized by
personnel and all members of the family
were administered Class A amnestics the
child's bed swayed lightly as an
instance of SCP
63302 emerges the instance resembles an
unknown creature though it is described
as having a large muscular frame the
instance walks to the opposite end of
the room hunching over and observing the
child for exactly 10 minutes as the SCP
63302 begins to stand further upright it
extends a retractable set of claws then
the child's teddy bear suddenly stands
drawing a bow and quiver SCP 63302
assumes a quadrapedal stands and snarls
before lunging Towards the bed the SCP
63301 fires a single Arrow towards the
SCP
63302 striking the instance directly in
its canine like snout as cp6 33-2
responds with a loud Huff reminiscent of
that of a bull or Bine the instances
battle for approximately 30 minutes the
longest recorded Sleepwalker event to
date both show abilities and skill sets
consistent with other SCP
63301 and-2 instances eventually SCP
6330 D2 has SCP 63301 pin to a nearby
wall and tries to strangle it the SCP
63302 then pulls one of SC P 6330 d1's
arrows from its arm plunging it into the
d1's chest then the -2 leans its head
towards the dash1 and Whispers into the
instance's right ear though audio
recordings cannot determine exactly what
was vocalized the SCP 63301 lifts up its
head staring blankly into SCP 6330 d2's
eyes it reaches behind its back pulling
out a small entirely wooden Glock 19
handgun the bear points the weapon into
SCP 60 330 d2's forehead and fires the
shot is silent and the SCP 6330 d2's
body falls limp black viscous fluid
sprays onto the wall the SCP 63301 hauls
SCP 6330 d2's corpse Towards the bed
noticeably limping it drags the body by
its large forearm and Dem manifests upon
reaching the underneath of the bed SCP
63301 returns and briefly stares around
the room before turning to the child it
climbs up a desk and finds a piece of
paper and a pen it goes on to write the
following note hello Timothy thank you
for always taking care of me it really
was fun I was able to repay the favor of
protecting you unfortunately I am hurt I
need to go I'm too weak to stay and I
just hope you'll remember me it's been
fun helping you I've enjoyed my time
under your care going into this I knew
it would happen the Sleepwalker is
coming for you I'm I'm just happy I
could do my job goodbye my friend I hope
I may see you soon to paraphrase noted
scientist Dr Hines doenz if I had a
nickel for every time there was a safe
class anomaly that manifests an absurdly
long entity that stuck underground and
pops up at multiple points around the
world and have two nickels which isn't a
lot but it's weird that it's happened
twice incidentally that happens to be
the case with SCP 1193 the bur Giant and
SCP 295 2 Corgi they're a pair of
mysterious creatures with very
thought-provoking similarities between
them but while both are exceedingly long
entities neither are particularly long
stories So today we're giving you a rare
SCP explained anomaly double feature
let's begin with the first of our two
very long boys SCP
1193 the exact nature of SCP 1193
anomalous qualities are challenging to
Define it appears to have biological
spatial and even temp temporal elements
SCP 1193 d01 the primary component of
SCP 1193 is a human arm that appears
completely normal in a genetic sense but
exhibits a freakish length and bone
structure this absurdly long arm was
first discovered in a drainage pipe
inside the basement of a telephone
switching station in Scottdale Arizona
where it had somehow become trapped how
this anomal was first discovered or by
whom is not recorded approximately 10 cm
below the drain gate of the pipe the arm
terminates in what seems to be a human
hand of indeterminate gender that is
unremarkable in both size and structure
upon initial examination the foundation
believed that the arm somehow threaded
through 35 M of drainage pipe but the
use of an endoscopic camera within the
pipe revealed that the reality is much
more severe the arm extends to at least
71 km beneath the Earth which is around
double the overall length of Scottdale
Arizona itself with elbows regular slly
spaced across every 4 km of arm elbows
below a depth of 26 km are slightly
retroflex to accommodate a 9° Southward
Bend in the drainage bore hole
interestingly the arm was also somehow
able to pass through the morovich
discontinuity which is the lower limit
of the Earth's crust and the volcanic
hot upper mantle the arm could actually
be longer than what we're currently
aware but the foundation doesn't have
any technology Hardy enough to follow
the arm all the way down into the Earth
conversations that Foundation staff have
had with what is believed to be SCP
11931 via the use of SCP
11932 indicates that the entity may have
no Thermo reception it has described
itself as being stuck in environments
that contextually should have either
extremely high or extremely low
temperatures this does not seem to
register with SCP
11931 this may serve as an explanation
as to why it is experiencing no
discomfort despite the Bold temperatures
having having been measured in excess of
674 de Cen but what exactly is SCP
11932 SCP 1193 d02 is a GPO 746 rotary
telephone with a topaz yellow plastic
exterior manufactured in
1971 because of the physical dimensions
of the phone it is too large to have
been delivered from below via the bore
hole so we know that SCP
11931 didn't put it there the work
theory of foundation researchers
assigned to the 1193 case is that the
phone was installed here specifically to
facilitate Communications with the
trapped SCP 1193 d01 it is attached to a
conventional twisted pair line which
enters the drainage pipe containing SCP
1193 d01 and ascends parallel to SCP
1193 d01 until endoscopy is no longer
practical who or what installed the
phone how and to what end Beyond just
chatting with the entity the foundation
doesn't presently know and the
investigation is ongoing one clue to the
purpose of SCP 1193 d02 is the fact that
its rotary dial has been permanently
glued in place rendering it unusable for
any kind of outgoing calls instead the
phone only receives calls and the only
calls it seems to receive are from a
being that seems to be a cp1
93-01 every weekday between 8:32 a.m.
and 10:34 p.m. Mountain Standard Time
the phone will ring up to five times
when answered by a member of foundation
Personnel an unidentified voice believed
to be that of SCP
11931 will willingly engage in
conversation with the person on the
other end of the line the foundation has
use this opportunity to question SCP
11931 about its own nature but it's
impossible to really know how reliable
the entity's ansers are the voice on the
line always refers to itself as a human
being and often mistakes the foundation
Personnel for authority figures such as
doctors firemen or police as a result of
this The Voice has been forthcoming with
information and the interviews have been
relatively straightforward there have
been notable similarities between the
information that the voice voluntarily
gives about itself and the known facts
about the condition of SCP
11931 lending credibility to the idea
that they are one and the same the
foundation fastidiously records
conversations with the voice and has
created a list of anomalous Det details
The Entity has surrendered during the
phone calls these include having human
features but an anomalous body plan so
the voice seems to have all the right
pieces for a human being but in a
bizarre configuration this may explain
the extremely long many jointed arm
whatever species or subspecies this
entity is it may not be alone as the
voice often refers to a cousin or some
kind of other relative who's on the way
to pick it up the voice often talks
about its feelings of discomfort or or
boredom at its state of being confined
it also makes reference to strange
seismic activity along the little Chino
fault complex an upper branch of the
Elenor fault zone of Southern California
over 300 Mi away from Arizona this may
be because the source of the voice is so
far underground it's still able to feel
the Tremors resonating upwards but one
of the most frequent trends of all in
these conversations is that the voice
venting frustration that its arm or some
other body part is stuck in an in
convenient place this list of places has
been exhaustive but includes handcuffs a
jelly jar a pipe a cast or in one
instance a gopher hole naturally this
has been seen as a cause for concern
among Foundation staff if SCP 1193 does
have spacially anomalous components is
it possible that someone could find a 70
km arm sticking out of a gopher hole or
a jelly jar sometime soon only time will
tell the foundation currently regards
any information about the physical form
of the entity beyond the exposed section
of the arm reached via endoscopy as
provisional in other words they really
have no idea what they're dealing with
here and are unlikely to find out for
sure anytime soon two phone
conversations with The Voice via SCP
11932 have been transcribed in the
addendum to 1193 is main file both are
conversations between the voice and Dr
Hassan IAL director of research at the
local SCP Containment site in the first
of two conversations recorded on March
24th 2008 Dr ibal asked who was calling
and the voice identified itself as David
The Voice or David appeared to be in its
usual state of frustration and distress
incorrectly believing that Dr ikbal was
a medical doctor at the hospital he was
currently trapped inside David implored
him to remove the cast from his bottom
arm when Dr ibal questioned David on
what exactly a bottom arm is he
responded with confusion when Dr ibal
told him that he was a research
scientist not a medical doctor David
became frustrated implied that Dr ibal
was incompetent and hung up the next
recorded call between Dr ibal and the
voice occurred exactly a year later in
this call The Voice incorrectly believed
that Dr ibal was a fireman The Voice
complained about having reached into its
oven to pull out some cakes becoming
stuck in the process he pleaded for help
saying that the oven was a tight fit
when Dr iul showed concern about the
potentially high temperatures within the
oven the voice didn't seem to know what
he meant in the end the voice became
frustrated and resolved to instead call
its Cousin It apologized and hung up
most calls appear to follow this General
structure because of the static and
Incredibly subdued nature of the anomaly
the foundation has deemed that SCP 1193
poses no meaningful risk of containment
breach as a result it has been given the
rare safe classification in order to
keep it properly contained the drainage
bore hole containing SCP 1193 d01 is
capped with a Tungsten Steel feel great
containing a locking 2.5 cm endoscopy
aperture meaning a small hole through
which to feed the endoscopic camera
every 48 Hours the drainage bore hole is
inspected with an endoscope for any
further developments concerning the
anomalous arm seismographic monitoring
devices are posted at 2 7 and 11 km
depths alongside the SCP 1193 d01 bore
hole seismic readings consistent with a
Subterranean movement are reported
immediately to site Direct ikbal in the
event of what is referred to as
Subterranean Containment Breach
researchers and guards working around
1193 are ordered to perform protocol
473a this involves severing SCP 1193
below the fifth elbow and back filling
remaining portions of the bore hole with
pressurized concrete to seal the hole
forever the SCP 1193 -02 phone is
monitored at all times by a train
Foundation interrogator and standard
procedure dictates that as CP 1193 3-02
is to be answered on or before the third
ring during these calls the interrogator
will attempt to elicit valuable
information about SCP 1193 from The
Voice and all valuable Intel will then
be recorded and loged the burri giant is
one of the more perplexing safe class
anomalies handled by the SCP Foundation
so much about its true nature is unknown
to this day but a concern that both we
and the foundation share is not knowing
where the entity's other limbs are
currently residing for all we know they
could be sticking out of an oven a go
hole or even a jelly jar somewhere near
you weird right well if you think that's
strange let us now introduce you to SCP
2952 or Corgi trust us if you're not
familiar with this one already you are
not ready for the strange turns this is
about to take in the simplest terms
Corgi is a cheerful Welsh PM Corgi with
an adorable face and a thick shiny coat
he's also over 30,000 km in length with
his head and front leg sticking out of
the ground in Portland Oregon and his
hindquarters being all the way over in a
rural area of Japan's kadawa District
his body weaves all across the globe
with sections of it surfacing all over
the Americas Europe and much of Asia
studies to find African or Australian
sections of SCP 2952 are still ongoing
despite his massive length there seems
to be no delay in reaction times either
you Pat his head in the USA and his tail
will immediately start wagging over in
Japan he's on honestly just precious he
also doesn't appear to need food or
water and thanks to the somewhat
sadistic experiments of one researcher
Mills we know that he can quickly
regenerate from all Damage Done to him
too okay now you're familiar with this
very good albeit very long lad it's time
for things to get really really strange
you see on the different exposed section
of SCP 29 52's body there are tiny
openings designated SCP
29521 stay with us here there are 324
openings all over the world some in
major cities others in Suburban areas
some in the tiniest and most rural of
hamlets at this point you probably have
the very reasonable question why are
there over 300 openings in this dog well
we're going to answer that but we can't
promise it won't just give you more
confusing questions when the openings
appear humanoid beings designated sccp
29522 will begin to exit the Corgi for
the sake of clarity we'll refer to these
little creatures as the Welsh Fair folk
or the Fay though there are many
different subgroups of Fay and we really
do mean little in this case on average
they're a puny 3 cm tall and they're
also invisible to the naked eye with
indirect methods like photographs or
videos being the only way to view them
though they do leave evidence of their
presence beyond their direct physical
appearances like Shadows or Footprints
Corgi acts as a kind of transport system
for these little people openings on the
Dex side of SCP 2952 take passengers
West while those on the sinistrous side
take passengers East passengers can be
seen entering and exiting at regular
intervals the foundation has even been
able to track a group of passengers
getting on the Corgi transit system and
getting off at a later stop from this
the foundation has been able to estimate
that the speed of the system is 120 kmph
excluding stops to let passengers on and
off along the way which for the record
is a pretty leisurely Pace by train
standards naturally the SCP Foundation
weren't exactly thrilled to learn about
an anomalous transit system that worked
to spread further anomalies all over the
world in fact that's kind of a nightmare
scenario for them so they marshaled
their Global forces located each of the
openings along the Torso of the Corgi
system and block them up at this point
the SCP Foundation were ready to give
themselves a pat on the back close up
shop for the night and go out for
afterwork drinks however there was one
thing that they'd all forgotten hell
hath no fury like a society of Welsh Fay
who've just had their daily commute
ruined the Council of tywi T their
ruling body doesn't take kindly to
having their Public Services messed with
and the manner of their retaliation was
less like a group of disgruntled
anomalous civil servants and more like a
kind of Fay mafia they would make the
foundation Ru the day they messed with
Corgi with a series of retaliatory
strikes that group of Interest like
chaos Insurgency and the children of the
Scarlet King could only dream of it
began with the kidnapping of Project
Director Stevens who'd authorized the
containment project he vanished from his
apartment and was replaced with an adult
European mole which seems to be the Fay
equivalent of leaving a horse's head in
the bed as an offer you can't refuse to
send a message but it didn't stop there
over the next 3 weeks 17 different
members of personnel specifically
construction workers who'd worked on the
project woke up to find that the walls
of their houses had been entirely
replaced by Poison Ivy and death cap
mushrooms and after 2 months researcher
Mills the weird dog torturer we told you
about earlier woke up with a highly
poisonous nightshade berries in his
mouth and Hawthorne Stakes driven
through his hands and feet crucifixion
style all perpetrated by some very upset
3-in transport workers at this point the
foundation put together who was behind
these attacks and decided to try to make
amends with the Fay whom they'd
understandably upset with their
treatment of Corgi a plan was drafted to
have all the SCP 29 52-1 entrances
unburied after this undertaking was
completed the Fay retribution came to an
end and most of the damage was undone
director Stevens was returned unharmed
the construction workers got their walls
back and well researcher Mills didn't
get better but I think we can all agree
that animal cruelty isn't really a crime
that we should be forgiving lightly
after all this chaos had transpired and
the SCP Foundation had fully made amends
director Stevens had a note left on his
desk by a Starling which then flew off
before it could be caught by the way can
we just take a second to appreciate that
the SCP Foundation has contained literal
demigods and interdimensional Horrors
but director Stevens was out foxed by a
bird wonderful those Fay truly are built
different anyway the note on his desk
translated from Welsh R thank you for
your prompt response to commuter
complaints and wonderful customer
service as such we have granted all
members of your organization
complimentary Transportation on our
Corgi system please send a to the
Council of the C office nearest you if
you have further questions G flock glove
director of Transportation the Council
of the tiwi tag and with tremendous
relief that the Slate had finally been
cleared the foundation decided that they
would accept the kind offer extended to
them by the council and send one of
their field agents to take a look inside
the Corgi system the field agent in
question was agent Elizabeth Davies
chosen for her Pleasant social skill and
Proficiency in Welsh with the intention
to take a ride in mind and connected to
an audio and video feeds linked back to
Central Command agent Davies touched the
site of Corgi this caused her to shrink
down to a height of 3.2 CM much like all
the other commuters she stepped into the
SCP 2952 entrance and found that on the
inside it looked not unlike a regular
train though some carriages seemed to be
in disrepair and everything was written
in Welsh oh and everything was made with
wood and plant matter too the chassis
appeared to be constructed from Birch
and all the seat cushions were made made
of flower petals it was all very
Whimsical honestly agent Davies struck
up conversations with some of the other
commuters one complained about delays
caused by the fact that Corgi was
suffering from kidney stones a problem
that the foundation is eager to help the
poor animal get over to keep the transit
system running smoothly she also chatted
with a sweet elderly lady on the train
who was getting people to sign a
petition to allow mice back onto the
Corgi transit system when agent Davies
Departed the system she patted the dog
and told him he was a good boy before
before returning to normal size since
January 5th 2017 the Corgi system and
its passengers have become invisible to
everyone who wasn't officially under SCP
Foundation employ this has allowed it
for its reclassification as a safe
anomaly so there you have it Folks at
least one of our two very long boys got
everything sorted out we love
occasionally doing a happy ending here
at SCP explained remember to stay tuned
for our next episode about the time that
scp-106 managed to get onto a school bus
what we did say occasionally roll up
roll up Step Right This Way ladies and
gentlemen on the other side of these
canvas doors you're about to witness
something so monstrous so hideous so
repulsive that it will turn your
stomachs and fill you with amazement the
creature you'll find in this tent has
been known to elicit all manner of
responses from well-to-do folks like
yourselves you may want to laugh at it
you may want to strike it down you may
even want to throw rotten fruit at it
and believe you me we are prepared for
that you will find all manner of Rotten
Tomatoes eggs and other festering foods
that are begging to be pelted for the
low low price of 5 cents per handful if
you follow me through these doors and
gather around this cage quietly perhaps
you will see it wait for your eyes to
adjust to the dark and hold your
revulsion until you cannot bear it
anymore only then will we get to look at
the papery gray skin sagging loose over
a swollen gut Marvel at its Tre trunk
legs barely strong enough to support its
own weight its deformed trunk that hangs
limp off the front of its face and its
ridiculous ears that flap nervously when
it's afraid don't be afraid of the Tusk
sticking out from its face or its cries
of pain and anguish instead hold your
tongues and wait for if you're patient
enough and perhaps with a slight beating
it may even play us a song with the
valves on its trunk then and only then
you're permitted to pelp the Elephant
Man with whatever you see fit as you
bask in the glory of Herman Fuller's
circus of the disquieting ree Freeman
didn't have much of a choice but to join
the circus at the age of 14 the cast out
son of a freed slave in New Orleans he
spent much of his early life wandering
the streets trying not to get into any
trouble in the late 1800s very few
places were interested in hiring a young
black man unless of course they were
looking to turn him back to the life
that his father had fought so hard to
escape that's why when Reese was out
fishing one afternoon and saw a big red
tent going up on the outskirts of town
he couldn't help but Wander Over much to
his surprise a group of black men were
the ones raising the Marquee they didn't
look like slaves either Reese had never
heard of a circus the closest he'd ever
come to seeing was a traveling
entertainment cart that would sometimes
pop up around town with a dancing bear
in a cage or a glass ball in a pack of
tarot cards the bright colored tents
that went up one after another were
enough to draw a crowd even the most
well-respected in New Orleans came out
for a look standing ankle deep in the
river Reese peered over at the man who
came out to address the throng dressed
in a long tail coat with a tall Top Hat
the man stood on a box of fruit and
waved a cane dramatically in the air
good folks of New Orleans what you're
about to witness tonight has never
before been seen this side of the
Mississippi wonders and amazement Galore
spectacle in intrigue mystery in Mayhem
and just a touch of the impossible I go
by the name of Herman Fuller the most
talented and notorious circus master in
the entire United States the dazzling
array of shows that I brought before you
is not for the faint of heart or the
weak of constitution your stomachs will
be turned and your minds may be altered
but it promises to be a knight that you
will never forget ree wasn't much
interested in any of what he had just
said this kind of Two Penny show was
reserved for the folks who had the money
to throw around on needless things like
smiling and having a nice evening what
Reese was far more interested in were
the groups of men working behind the
scenes pulling various carts and setting
up all of the Stalls a lot of them
didn't look much older than him a grin
spread across his face as SCP 4409
insisted on being interviewed in the
dark with all the lights in the
interview chamber switched off Dr Simon
Crossley entered the room and sat down
across from the Elephant Man even in the
dim light though he was able to still
make out part of the man's features the
ivory tusks the hanging nose and the
nervously twitching ears the man had
been picked up in St Louis where local
police had found him panhandling in the
streets while he certainly seemed
harmless enough it was important for the
foundation to take him in just to be
sure sitting in the dark interview room
reys Freeman was apprehensive at first
about telling his side of the story a
life of being mocked spat on and chased
out of towns had left him with a real
distrust of other people that was
probably made worse by his apprehension
at being put in another cage within the
foundation he told Dr Crossley that he
was born as normal as could be that his
current ghastly Affliction was something
done to him quite some time ago but as
much as it pained him to recollect it
was a tale that he knew he'd probably
have to tell Dr Crossley replied that he
was all ears it took Dr Crossley a few
seconds to realize his faux paw SCP 4409
glared at him before continuing to
explain how he was made the way he was
reys Freeman had managed to land a job
with the circus surprisingly easily
despite having no previous experience
and no references to back him up Herman
Fuller took a shine to him it was menial
work and not many folks were up to doing
it but since reys had never had a job
before he he didn't know any better he
started out at the bottom of the ladder
scraping out feces washing down old
cages and carrying heavy crates the one
scrawny 14-year-old boy quickly turned
into a stocky 17-year-old with broad
shoulders and strong legs they would
travel from town to town across most of
the United States stopping off in major
cities for weeks at a time to bring in
as much money as possible before moving
on Reese didn't save much of that money
but he didn't mind the fact that he got
two meals a day and something to do with
himself was enough in fact he kind of
enjoyed sleeping on top of the carts as
the horses pulled them across the dusty
American roads the one thing that always
seemed to affect him though was that he
was never allowed to actually see inside
the tents he would see folks come and go
through the canvas doors week after week
but was never allowed so much as a peak
inside himself the older guys were
responsible for throwing the canvas
sheets over the cages which would remain
that way as they traveled not having
seen much of the world at that point
Reese didn't have much of an idea of
what could be in those cages perhaps
some kind of animal from a foreign
country something from Africa or Asia
they made all kinds of noise Reese said
that most of them sounded like humans
but then they'd go and make strange
animal sounds that no human mouth could
ever produce one night his curiosity got
the better of him hanging back before
the crowds got into the tent he Sid
stepped over to the entrance making sure
that no one saw him and took a peek
through the doorway it was dark inside
too dark to make out much of what was
happening the crowd of people was
standing between him and the cage all
jostling and leaning this way and that
trying to make out whatever it was that
was inside a screeching sound filled the
air making the whole crowd and Reese
outside jump right standing on his
tiptoes he tried his best to see what
was moving around in that cage it seemed
to be moving around like a person
lurching this way and that but the sound
sounds coming from it sounded more like
a bird and sure enough after a moment a
huge pair of disproportionately ugly
Wings stretched out from either side of
the creature flapping and sending a rush
of air through the tent so powerful that
it blew the flap wide open in front of
him just as Herman Fuller turned around
to see him standing there ree bolted and
hid behind one of the carts he was going
to be in trouble for this he was sure of
it it was one of Fuller's only rules of
the circus and he had just gone and
broken it he was in the hottest water
imaginable but as nighttime fell and the
drags of the spectators wandered out of
the tent Fuller seemed to be in too bad
a mood at all watching him from a
distance ree got the impression that he
might not actually be in as much trouble
as he thought Fuller caught his eye and
came over Kane twirling and Top Hat
sitting jauntily at top his head Reese
got off on the wrong foot apologizing
right away for spying into the tent the
circus Master just laughed it off and
slapped him on the back reys my boy
don't worry about it I've got much
bigger plans for you much much bigger
that night as Reese lay in bed he had a
terrible dream about what he had seen in
the tent that day circus of the
disquieting was certainly an apt title
for this place the image of that strange
shadowy bird person in the cage haunted
his nightmares until suddenly two pairs
of strong hands gripped him and ripped
him out of his sleep he knew better than
to fight back this was surely going to
be his comeuppance for breaking Fuller's
rules earlier they dragged him into the
main tent where there was an oil lamp in
the middle Illuminating what looked like
a heavy wooden operating table his
wrists and ankles were strapped in and
then the two men left him alone he had
half a mind to scream but with all the
Caged up creatures from the circus
around him he doubted anyone would pay
him much mind it was almost an hour
before Herman Fuller walked into the
tent by this point reys expected him to
be walking in with surgical equipment
gloves maybe even a saw but the man had
nothing in his bare hands Herman Fuller
asked him if he ever heard of Joseph
Merrick Reese didn't answer of course he
had heard of the Elephant Man the whole
world had been talking about Joseph
Merrick for months a man born so
hideously deformed that people had
compared him to an elephant though the
resemblance wasn't that convincing this
sentiment was clearly shared by Fuller
who placed one hand on either side of
ree's face and began to softly massage
his cheeks explaining how disappointed
he was that merik didn't actually look
all that much like an elephant Reese's
cheeks started to hurt as the man
massaged him almost as if he was
stretching and pulling at his face
finding loose skin the boy asked Fuller
what he was doing the circus Master just
smiled at him and explained that it was
an old technique handed down in his
family a gift he called it he started
touching Reese's nose gently pulling at
it with more and more pressure much to
ree's surprise he felt his nose
elongating growing longer and longer in
the man's hand he tried to Twitch his
face and was starting to find that his
new nose twitched along with it the
longer it grew the more painful it felt
the skin and flesh from his head being
ripped and pulled into a new shape at
several points Reese felt ready to pass
out from the agony but the circus Master
kept talking to him kept him awake
through the whole ordeal as he molded
the boy's face like clay into the shape
of an elephant lying on the bench
panting reys could see his trunk from
between his two eyes it was a nightmare
that was all it was but then Fuller
reached under the workbench and lifted
out a small hand drill one by one he
punched holes into the top of Reese's
trunk installing little valves like a
trumpet as he went standing back to
admire his handiwork he told Reese that
he would be his new favorite attraction
my boy I have made you into a star the
tusks did not come straight away over
the course of several months they slowly
and painfully emerged from his deformed
jaw his elephantine legs were also not
part of his initial transformation but
instead came as a result of health
issues he developed while being trapped
in a cage for several decades crowds of
people would come and go flocking to see
the Elephant Man having spent the first
part of his life constantly hungry Reese
was now being overfed every day hands
would come to his cage and force him to
eat Rich fatty foods denying him any
possibility of exercise the broad
shoulders and strong legs that he had
developed while working at the circus
melted away under layers and layers of
fat his skin went gray and papery
folding and wrinkling in on itself
either from Fuller's magic or just from
a lack of sunlight whatever it was with
every passing day ree Freeman steadily
became more and more hideous SCP 4409
was stuck in the circus for much of his
life eventually Herman Fuller moved on
and is currently being hunted by the SCP
Foundation when he did SCP 4409 was able
to bargain for its freedom from the
circus wandering from City to City never
sticking around for very long SCP 449
begged for change at the side of the
road some people would feel sympathy
While most would feel horror at its
disfigurement from its years trapped in
a cage SCP 4409 has developed severe
health issues including gout severe
obesity and metabolic syndrome while in
Foundation custody it is fed a special
diet to counteract these conditions as
of yet the foundation has no way of
reversing what was done to Reese Freeman
in the tent in the 1800s as Reese poses
no threat to the foundation he is
allowed to live with relative Freedom or
at least as much Freedom as a contained
SCP can earn earn his health condition
severely limits his Mobility around site
66 a low security residential
containment area unable to walk even
moderate distances SCP 4409 heavily
relies on the use of a cane and a
heavyduty walker capable of supporting
up to 140 kg researchers listen intently
at his door waiting to hear if he's ever
going to play a sad song on his trumpet
but no sound ever emerges except for his
heavy breathing and spluttering cough it
appears that having spent decades locked
in a small cage a sedentary life is all
he knows now with every opportunity to
exercise read books and take up new
hobbies SCP 4409 appears unable to
engage with anything other than sitting
and staring at the same spot on the wall
every day if an animal has spent its
whole life living in a zoo and finds in
its old age that one of the walls has
fallen down what use has it in taking a
step outside now check out SCP 082
Ferdinand the cannibal and SCP 5031 yet
another murder monster